Emmy Stone Christine Jardine and Minerva
Wilson
Helen Morgan
carers and care workers bill
second reading what day
Friday
the 24th of November
thank you
Clark will now will now proceed to read
the orders of the
as amended in Committee of the whole
house to be considered
we begin with government new Clause 17
with which it will be convenient to
consider the other selected new Clauses
and amendments as listed on the
selection paper Now call Minister Derek
to move government new clause 70.
thank you madam Deputy speaker and with
your permission can I take this
opportunity on behalf of the home office
to pay tribute to those border Force
officers who have nobly volunteered to
serve in Sudan uh this week to support
British Nationals and others as they're
being processed and swiftly returned to
the United Kingdom the Home Secretary
and I Want To Praise their
professionalism and sense of service and
Duty
speaker before I set out the key
government amendments that we've tabled
for report it's worth reminding the
house of why the government has brought
forward this vital bill
a sovereign state must have control of
its own borders we quite properly have
an immigration system that determines
who can come to the UK lawfully whether
it's to visit to study to work or for
other legitimate reasons are immigration
and Asylum system also makes generous
provision to provide Sanctuary for
people seeking protection indeed we've
offered such protection in different
ways to nearly half a million people
since 2015.
but the people of this country are
rightly frustrated if a self-selected
group of individuals can circumvent
those controls by paying people
Smugglers to Ferry them across the
channel on a small boat
why apply to come to this country for
employment
if you can instead arrive on a small
boat claim Asylum and then as one of the
amendments to the bill today suggests
acquire the right to work here after 12
months
illegal migration I will in a moment but
if I can make this opening Point illegal
migration undermines the Integrity of
our immigration system it puts an
unsustainable pressure on our housing
health education and Welfare Services
and it undermines public confidence in
our Democratic processes and the rule of
law that's why we want to stop the boats
and secure our borders and this bill is
dedicated to that goal it will send a
clear message that if you enter the
United Kingdom illegally
you will not be able to build a life
here instead you're liable to be
detained and you will be removed either
back to your home country if it's safe
to do so or a safe Third Country such as
Rwanda I'll happily give way to the
right Old Gentleman
being the host to believe that it would
act as a pool factor that people will
come here on the basis of the
possibility that we might pass an
amendment out giving Asylum Seekers the
right to work because if that's The
Minister's case even by his standards
it's particularly poor
it is a pull factor to the UK that
individuals can work in the gray economy
here that is a cause of serious concern
and if we were to add an additional pull
factor to the UK by enabling people to
work more quickly then I think it would
be yet another reason why individuals
would choose to come to the country and
it it's a point that I'll return to in
answer to other other questions before
us today
but
the vast majority I won't give away at
the moment the vast majority of those
individuals coming on small boats are
coming from an obvious place of safety
in France with a fully functioning
Asylum system so they're choosing to
make that additional Crossing they are
essentially Asylum Shoppers even if they
ultimately came from a place of danger
and they're doing that because they
believe the United Kingdom is a better
place for them to make their claim and
to build a future and so their ability
to work is obviously a part of that
calculation and it's something that our
northern European counterparts say
frequently let me make let me make some
progress and then I'll return to uh I'll
return to those members who want to to
intervene it's important that we get
this bill right I do understand
the complexity of the legal and
operational challenges that we face in
enacting this legislation we must be
alert to those who will seek to use
every possible tactic to thwart and
frustrate the operation of the ACT
we've seen that with our groundbreaking
partnership with Rwanda and we'll see it
again with this bill
so since introduction we've continued to
examine how to make the bill as robust
as possible as well as reflecting on the
debates in committee last month and the
government amendments before the house
today are a reflection of that further
work and consideration
we've repeatedly been clear
and that as we reduce illegal immigrants
coming in small boats and through other
forms of clandestine entry we will free
up capacity for more people to come to
this country through safe and legal
routes
well I'll give way to to well let me
give way to the The Honorable agent
she's been right on her leg she's been
waiting on them we know from 2021 that
71 of Asylum climb Asylum claims were
successful a further 47 were successful
on appeal these are not illegal
migrations so why if this is successful
claims why therefore are we not allowing
people to work or is he trying to make
the whole system illegal when people
come in and thereby reducing our
standing in the rule of law
there's a number of points there on the
question of work there is a legitimate
point of view as I said on a number of
occasions that those seeking a
determination should have the right to
work we disagree because we want to
reduce the pull factors to the United
Kingdom not add to them and deterrence
as I've said throughout my time in this
role has to be suffused to every aspect
of our approach and creating a situation
where individuals can quickly access the
UK labor market is not sensible if we
want to reduce those people coming here
in the first place
let me return to safe and legal Roots
which I know is an issue but let me make
my remarks and I'll I'll come to The
Honorable gentle but this is an issue
clearly of interest to many members on
both sides of the house and in
particular I'd like to note and pay
tribute to
my honorable friend the member for East
Worthing and showroom with whom I've
been having a number of uh significant
conversations in recent weeks he is Keen
to see early progress on this front the
government accepts the need for greater
clarity about the safe and legal routes
available to those seeking refuge in the
United Kingdom whilst reiterating the
point that it's simply not feasible for
this country to accept all those who may
seek to come here
that's why I'm happy to commend to the
house my honorable Friends new Clause 8
and Amendment 11. these would first
require the Home Secretary to lay before
Parliament within six months of Royal
Ascent a report detailing existing and
proposed additional safe and legal
routes for those in need of protection
we will aim to implement the proposed
new routes as soon as practicable and in
any event by the end of 2024
secondly the Amendments would require
the Home Secretary to commence the
consultation on the annual number of
people to be admitted through safe and
legal routes within three months of
Royal ascent
I'll give way to the The Honorable
gentleman
couldn't answer this earlier so perhaps
the immigration Minister can what is the
safe and legal route available today to
a young person in Sudan who wants to
flee the violence there and come to the
United Kingdom
to answer the question we've
consistently said that those seeking
Sanctuary should do so in the first safe
country and with respect to the
developing situation in Sudan the United
Nations is operating in most if not all
of the countries surrounding Sudan I met
last week with the assistant
commissioner of the UN HCR in which we
discussed exactly this point and so the
best advice clearly would be for
individuals to present to the unhcr the
United Kingdom like many countries Works
closely with the unhcr and we already
operate safe and legal routes in
partnership with them that safe and
legal route is available today and in
fact to answer directly the The
Honorable gentleman I will give away to
The Honorable in a moment the UK is the
fourth largest recipient of any country
in the world of individuals through
those routes operated by the unhcr so
his Central contention that the UK is
somehow not a generous and compassionate
country that we are not working with
organizations like the UN HCR in this
regard is factually incorrect we are
working with them closely in addition to
that we have a family reunion scheme
which has enabled more than 50 000
refugees to come to the United Kingdom
in recent years and to meet up with
their family members who have also
sought refuge in the United Kingdom as
refugees and that scheme is available
all over the world and so if by The
Honorable gentleman's example was a
young person with family in the United
Kingdom that individual could through
the family reunion scene come here in
addition to that the point made in the
bill is that we will expand those safe
and legal routes over the course of the
next 12 months or so so that even more
individuals can make use of them I'll
give way to The Honorable lady
forgiving we and I think he's in danger
of taking the unhcr's name and vein
because they've issued a statement which
says the unhcr wishes to clarify that
there is no mechanism through which
refugees can approach unhcr with the
intention of seeking asylum in the UK
there is no Asylum Visa or cue for the
United Kingdom would you like to create
the record
no the the I mean The Honorable lady uh
may not well well with all due respect
The Honorable lady I met the assistant
commissioner of the unhcr last week and
had this conversation directly with her
so whatever she may be quoting on her
iPhone I would prefer to take at face
value what that I've had the discussion
with the assistant commissioner but the
point is the point is that the unhcr
selects individuals who have registered
with them and who they have given
Refugee status to go to other countries
on existing safe and legal routes and it
is currently their discretion as to who
they uh put in the direction of the the
United Kingdom that was a choice when
the UK established that scheme because
the then conservative government took
the view and it's a perfectly legitimate
one that we would offer complete
discretion to the United Nations to
select those people who they felt were
the most vulnerable in the world and
help them to come to the UK
we've already opened the conversation
with the UN as to how we will establish
a new safe and legal route and there's a
range of options as we as to how we
might uh configure that I'd be pleased
to give way to my arrival friends I'm
grateful to my right I'm a friend for
giving away I wonder if I might assist
him in this issue issue on the unhcr
because I've also seen the quote from
the unhcr what the unhcr is saying as
far as I can see is that somebody cannot
just turn up the unhcr and say I want to
go I have asylum in the United Kingdom
but what the United Kingdom has as an
arrangement with unhcr is that we say to
them we will take a certain number of
refugees or Asylum Seekers and will they
please identify those who are most
vulnerable and therefore those who
should be coming under our scheme
there's not that incompatibility that's
being suggested
girlfriend is is absolutely right
um and of course that is a choice by the
UK as to how we structure any safe and
legal route whether we work with the
United Nations uh or indeed any other
organization it's not impossible for the
UK to say that we wish to take
individuals from particular countries or
regions but the choice and as I say I
think it was a it was a perfectly valid
one uh in the recent past was to give
that discretion to the experts at the
unhcr rather than to Fetter their
discretion I'll give way to uh
yeah I'm not right on but anyway um
thank you I'm very very grateful to the
minister um can I just take us back to
the issue of People in Sudan at the
moment because you referred to
um Brave officials from his Department
who are out there what is the advice
being given if um a family member who
has children under the age of 18 who may
not be properly documented for all sorts
of complicated reasons at the moment
given the situation in Sudan what will
they be able to get on an airplane will
they end up having to make some kind of
determination when they get to Cyprus
what's going to be the situation
yeah well that we've so far been calling
individuals and families forwards in
order of priority and those uh in Sudan
should check the uh foreign Commonwealth
officers published advice to see that
there is discretion for Border Force
officers where they uh are where British
passport holders or those who have uh
leave to enter the United Kingdom
present with miners where there is
credible evidence that they are their
own children so as to ensure that the
family unit wherever possible stays
together I think that's the right
approach and we've worked closely with
border Force to ensure that the group of
officers that we have in Sudan have the
correct guidelines to operate that
politin to the best of my knowledge
today we've not encountered any any
issues but of course we're getting
regular updates uh to ensure that that
um that's functioning properly I'll give
way to the The Honorable gentleman
I just wanted to call the attention of
the house to another safe and legal
route which exists at the moment which
was is the community sponsorship
Arrangement which was introduced by my
right honorable friend the member for
maidenhead as Home Secretary and this
enables communities to welcome refugees
from around the world does he not agree
that this is a really good model that we
should expand in future I do and I
commend that uh wholeheartedly I took
part in in one sense of successor to
that scheme the homes for Ukraine scheme
and it was an incredibly rewarding
experience for me and my family and the
principal at the heart of that is that
it's not purely a matter for the state
to provide support but there are
individuals or groups churches
synagogues mosque you might want to come
forward to gather support and funding to
meet the state halfway and assist those
people to come to the UK that scheme is
available we would like more people to
take part in it and it's exactly the
sort of scheme that could be considered
alongside the further expansion of safe
and legal routes if I may make some more
more progress but I'd be pleased to to
revert to The Honorable lady in a moment
um if I can turn to the other issue that
my honorable friend uh the the member
for East Worthington raised in committee
the issue of unaccompanied children
again we've listened to the points that
he an honorable and right honorable
members on both sides of the house have
raised as I've repeatedly said this is a
morally complex issue there are no
simple answers each have trade-offs but
our primary concern must be the welfare
of children both here and abroad we need
to ensure that the UK does not become a
destination that is specifically
targeted by people Smugglers
specializing in Children and Families
I'm I'll make a little bit of progress
I'm also acutely concerned that we
balance that with the very real
safeguarding risks posed by young adults
pretending to be children
this is not a theoretical issue it's one
that we see every day unfortunately
today a very large number of young
adults do pose as children in fact even
with our current method of age
assessment around 50 percent of those
people who are assessed are ultimately
determined to be adults and of course
we've seen some very serious and
concerning incidents in recent months
few more so than that raised in this
house by my honorable friend the member
for Bournemouth West when one of his
constituents Thomas Roberts was murdered
by an individual who'd entered the UK
posing as a minor and during his time in
the UK had both been in education in the
loving care of foster parents and in
other settings in which he was in close
proximity to genuine children I'd have
to give away to The Honorable Lady it's
the awful case of Thomas Roberts I have
asked him repeatedly why it was not
known that the murderer was wanted for
murder in Serbia and white also wasn't
known that he had already been turned
down for asylum in another European
country why did the Border Force why did
the authorities not know that
information
well as I said in answer
um in the a German debate that we had in
the house on this issue
um I have commissioned a review of all
of the circumstances surrounding that
most serious case so that we can
understand
[Music]
the multiple failures that may have
happened uh whilst that individual has
been in the United Kingdom and what
lessons we need to learn separate to
that I have taken further steps to
enhance the security checks that are
conducted when individuals arrive at the
Western jet foil and at manston aided by
the change in the law that I made
earlier in the year so that we have in
extremists up to 96 hours in which to
hold individuals in that setting whilst
we're conducting those Security checks
I'm working closely with the security
services police and the National Crime
agency in that regard if there are other
things that we need to do we will do
them and if there are other databases
that we should be arguing for access to
then we will certainly do so because
it's critical that we secure our borders
in this regard
let me make some progress if I may
we've been clear that the power to
remove unaccompanied children would only
be exercised in very limited
circumstances principally for the
purposes of affecting a family reunion
or to return someone to their safe
country of origin
now if I may just finish the power then
I'll come to them government Amendment
174 makes this clear on the face of the
bill whilst future proofing the bill
against the risk that the people
Smugglers will seek to endanger more
young lives and break up more families
by loading yet more unaccompanied
children onto the small boats I'll give
way to uh the right honorable gentleman
I'm very grateful to my iPhone befriend
and on the face of it I very much also
welcome the government Amendment 174 on
the limitations the removal of children
the prescription that's put within it
however he's alluded to the fact that
further down in that Amendment it sets
out that the Home Secretary can pass
regulations uh to set out any other
circumstances at a later date
um is he referring to changes to the way
that the people Smugglers may may
operate will this be an affirmative
procedure in Parliament and what sort of
circumstances does he anticipate you may
be dealing with
well what we do know with this uh
situation is that is a fast-moving one
and that the people Smugglers are
individuals and businesses that will
stop at nothing and stoop to no new low
and so what we want to do is retain a
degree of discretion
course accountable to Parliament and we
would ensure that it is an affirmative
procedure
um so that this would have to or at
least it'll be an opportunity for
Parliament to debate this should be
concerned with the approach of any
future uh Home Secretary but let me be
clear that the government's position is
that we only see today the use of this
power being for those two very limited
and I think understandable uh and uh and
sensible suggestions there are two
routes that are used today judiciously
we do although it's very hard to do this
uh seek to reunify unaccompanied minors
with their family members and succeed in
a small number of cases and we do remove
miners from the UK back home to Safe
countries always making sure that social
services or appropriate authorities are
awaiting them on their return those
things happen today and we want to see
that they continue and if anything that
we take further advantage of them I'll
give way to them lady
right I think no
tiles will just
the government's focus is too much on
the people smartness rather than the
damage that it's caused to vulnerable
children who are already traumatized and
the whole process that the government is
and proposing is re-traumatizing already
deeply traumatized young people
well on the broader point let me
reassure her that as a parent both
myself the Home Secretary and the Prime
Minister gave these questions a great
deal of thought and our motivation was
the best interests of children we don't
want to see children being put into
dinghies and seeing their lives placed
in danger and when you do see that
that is a harrowing experience that
lives with you we have to take these
steps to ensure that when we operate I
will give way to the The Honorable lady
when we operationalize the scheme that's
at the heart of this bill
the UK isn't then targeted by people
Smugglers specializing in families and
children I'll give away
giving away on that question of children
I think everyone is absolutely agreed at
the compassionate expression that the
minister has expressed but in Kent we do
take the majority of the unaccompanied
children to look after
um does he agree that the safest place
for those children is to be in the care
of the French authorities and not on
those boats in the first place and how
will this bill assist with that
the key the key element at the heart of
this bill is deterrence we want to deter
individuals families or adults from
going into these dinghies putting
themselves at the best of people
Smugglers that is the way that we
ultimately protect children if we allow
this issue to escalate as is not the
intention but is The Logical conclusion
of those uh who oppose this bill it will
simply see more children placed into
these boats and we have to stop that
that is what we're setting out to do
here I would as The Honorable lady
raises the point I would praise the
authorities in Kent to have gone above
and beyond to support young people I've
recently visited uh the facilities there
I'll give way to the honorable and then
I should make more progress
to learn of pregnant women on these
boats arriving to the UK and does he
agree that perhaps they should be exempt
from the provisions around removals in
this bill
don't want to see pregnant women placed
in a a difficult or compromising
position the scheme is structured in
such a way that there is a suspensive
claim that can be brought where there is
serious or irreversible harm
which is in in most cases physical harm
which would prevent an individual being
placed on a flight either back home to
their own country if it's a safe place
to do so or to a safe Third Country like
Rwanda and the usual Fitness to fly
procedures will apply and so a pregnant
woman would not be placed on a flight to
Rwanda or elsewhere unless it was it was
safe to do so and there's long-standing
conventions of practice on how we would
make that judgment
uh let me make some progress uh if I may
on the issue of Detention of
unaccompanied children I understand the
concerns that a number of uh honorable
and right-home members have raised about
the prolonged Detention of children
without the authority of a court and I
thank those members including the member
for East Worthing and Shoreham for very
constructive engagement with us on this
and other matters as a result of those
discussions we've introduced government
amendments
134 and 136
to enable a time limit to be placed on
the Detention of an unaccompanied child
where the detention is for the purposes
of removal
I acknowledge his and other members
concerns indeed I share them and can
commit to work with my honorable friend
and others uh including uh the right
humble lady for Chelmsford uh with with
whom I've had a number of conversations
to set out the new time scale under
which genuine children may be detained
for the purposes of removal without the
authority of the court and what
appropriate support should be provided
within detention recognizing the
obligations under the children's act
which is an important piece of
legislation I can also confirm to The
Honorable gentleman and others that it's
Our intention that children where there
is no age dispute are not detained for
any longer than is absolutely necessary
with particular regard to the risk of
absconding and suffering significant
harm
trust these amendments and these
commitments will assuage the concerns
that were raised at the committee stage
by my honorable friend and he won't feel
the need to press his own Amendment 138
on this issue
for giving away as he said the
Amendments one three four one three six
bring in the opportunity to introduce
regulations to setting time limits
um in past practice when there's been a
contentious issue like this across the
house it's often been the case that the
government will bring for draft
regulations before the end of the
passage of the bill in both houses could
he give that assurance that we can see
the detail of what the government is
thinking
Minister I I'm not able to give that
Assurance today but I will give that
careful consideration and revert to um
the right honorable gentleman we need to
make sure that we get these uh careful
considerations and as I said earlier
difficult judgments right that we learn
the lessons from when uh children have
been detained in the recent past and I
know that he is very aware of that and
it in his constituency is that
immigration removal Center that he's
been very involved with in the uh in his
constituency duties and we want to make
sure that we are only detaining children
the most limited circumstances and in
the right forms of accommodation with
the correct uh scrutiny uh and
accountability and in the further policy
development that we intend to do
um I have recently spoken with the
children's commissioner and asked her to
assist us and to give us her expert
opinion
and I'm very open and Keen to work with
any member across the house who has
expertise to bring to bear to this issue
and if I may turn to the question that
was raised in committee stage regarding
modern slavery
the amendment four in the name of my
right honorable friend the member for
chingford and Woodford green and
supported by amongst others my right
honorable friend the member for
maidenhead both of whom are
International Champions of this issue
and played critical roles in
establishing the UK as a leading force
in modern slavery prevention and the
protection of those who've proven to be
victims
this issue
this relates to the issue of modern
slavery and it's an issue that's also
addressed in the Amendments 12 and 16
from the writing member for normanton
pontefract and Castleford and amendments
73 and 74 from the member for Glasgow
Central
the bill is intended to stop the boats
people are risking their lives by making
dangerous Crossings as well as putting
unprecedented pressure on our Public
Services
amending these Clauses to create
exemptions that could lead to abuse of
our modern slavery protections
and risk uh undermining the very purpose
of the bill is obviously something that
we need to think very carefully about
but I understand of course that my
writable friends from chingford at
Woodford green and maidenhead and others
in the preparation of their amendments
have thought in particular about how we
can prevent individuals who have been in
the UK for a sustained period of time
from being exploited by human
traffickers or if they are already being
from being deterred from escaping that
modern slavery or raising concerns with
civil society or law enforcement bodies
those are serious issues and ones that I
want to take forward with them listening
to their unrivaled expertise through the
passage of the bill and seeing if there
are ways in which we can address and
assuage their concerns
it's for this reason
that we will look at what more we can do
to provide additional protections to
individuals who suffered exploitation in
the UK
now I would remind my right honorable
friends uh that the modern slavery
Provisions in the bill are time limited
recognizing the exceptional
circumstances we currently face in
respect of the illegal and dangerous
Channel Crossings unless renewed these
Provisions will expire two years after
commencement they do take advantage of
and express provision within the
European convention against trafficking
that foresaw that there might be
circumstances in which there was a
sufficient risk to public disorder a
crisis that merited taking this kind of
action the government would argue that
we are in that such that's a very that
that moment now and for that reason we
need to apply this limited exemption uh
I'll give way to the 100 Personnel of
course I'll revert so thank you madam
Deputy speaker the minister of quite
rightly singled out two of my colleagues
with flattery to try and help him but he
didn't single me out so he's going to
get it in the net
um
what happens minister if a 16 year old
in Moldova is told that she's got a job
in a restaurant in Belfast
she's provided with a Romanian passport
she comes across here on an airplane
with false documents but when she gets
to Belfast she doesn't get a job she's
put in a terrorist house forced into
prostitution the lock is on the outside
of the bedroom she's effectively
repeatedly raped the police
break that ring rescue her
at the moment she gets protection she
gets looked after she's helped in the
prosecution
this bill changes that and please tell
me why because this person has been
trafficked
not on a small boat
and exploited here
to why can't you accept the bill that's
in my my right honorable friend's name
because it seems to me there is no risk
Minister and if you I want your bill to
succeed but this is um yes thank you
Monday thanks
well I apologize to my honorable friend
for not uh praising his long-standing
instances and the very good conversation
that he and I had uh recently in which
he made exactly the point that um he's
just raised on the floor of the house we
are concerned about the kind of cases
that he raises and about those
individuals who are exploited within the
United Kingdom uh what we are Keen to do
is to ensure that that is not
inadvertently turned into a loophole
that would undermine the broader scheme
one of the uh existing protections
within the bill for an individual such
as that is the provision that if you are
cooperating in a police investigation
then uh the duty to remove will be
suspended and so if somebody uh was uh
in exactly the position that he raised
then they should of course uh go to the
law enforcement authorities and at that
point the provision in the bill the
safeguard that we put in the bill would
apply and they wouldn't be removed from
the country I'll give way to well let me
go to the right on the journal first I I
I'm going to speak to the amendment
shortly I'm sure and my writable friend
and others I just wanted to raise one
particular point he talks about uh
inadvertently I just wonder how the
government Amendment 95 is inadvertent
in the sense that it gives sweeping
powers to the Secretary of State to
decide whether somebody is genuinely
giving evidence regardless please and
then the last Clause is puzzling to me
which it says the secretary of state
must have regard to guidance issued by
the secretary of state which is the same
person I think and I'm not sure quite
how that balances out the desire to be
balanced on this that's
um well that was uh that thank you very
much speaker that that provision ensures
that where an individual has presented
to the authorities and the police may
have opened an investigation the police
would then make a submission to the Home
Secretary who would then decide whether
that uh it was sufficiently Advanced for
the provisions in the bill to apply I
think that's a sensible Safeguard but
this is exactly the sort of vision which
I'm happy to continue to work with the
right home gentlemen I'll give way to
the right honorable lady
offense giving away and picking up the
point that my right honorable friendly
member for chingford and Woodford green
has made I think we were all surprised
when we saw Amendment 95 coming from the
government because what amendment 95
says is not that the police can make an
application to the Secretary of State
and nice order and you know so it says
they must assume that the person cannot
stay in the United Kingdom unless there
are compelling circumstances
determined initially by the Secretary of
State endorsed by the secretary of state
that says that person can stay there
well that is the procedure that I've
just outlined the the police
uh police forces would uh apply to the
Secretary of State who would then make
the determination that that she just
describes I think that's that is an
important Safeguard uh to ensure that
there is rigor uh placed around the
issue I will make some progress because
this is a short debate and I think it's
important that we we enable people to uh
to make
um well it was only a few moments ago
that members opposite were saying this
was too short uh debate although I would
gently remind them that in both days of
committee stage we ran out of speakers
including on the uh the SMP side
um
now
I really should make progress actually
because uh I I worry that we're we're
going to run out of time uh if I can
turn next to the uh question around
um
the uh the the removal of individuals
it's always been Our intention I'm sorry
apologies I was going to say a few words
uh in response to the new Clause 15
um and uh to to speak to the issue about
suspected terrorists
um of course I welcome the shadow home
secretaries belated albeit limited
endorsement of the duty on the Home
Secretary to make arrangements for the
removal of persons who enter the UK
unlawfully presumably including removal
to Rwanda that Duty applies across the
board saving the case of unaccompanied
children so again new Clause 15 is in
our opinion unnecessary protecting the
publicist the government's first
priority and the bill includes powers to
detain illegal entrants and where it is
necessary to release a person on
immigration bail there are existing
powers to apply terrorism prevention and
investigation measures t-pins where
appropriate they give the security
service and the police powerful measures
to help manage the risk of terrorism and
they're considered of course on a
case-by-case basis in used as a last
resort if prosecution or deportation
isn't possible we therefore judge that
new Clause 15 doesn't add anything to
the provisions of the bill or existing
counter terrorism powers
have more Sympathy for the amendment 184
which is tabled by my honorable friend
the member for Dover uh in that is
seeking to be a constructive
contribution to the debate on how we
manage the clear risk posed by terrorism
it's already the case that all Asylum
claims must be declared inadmissible
under the bill this is the case in
respect of Any Human Rights claim in
respect of a person's home country where
we're seeking to remove someone to a
safe Third Country it is right that they
should be able to challenge that removal
where they face a real risk of serious
and irreversible harm albeit that that
is a very limited uh ground and the bill
provides for that but we will always
seek to affect removal as soon as
possible particularly where somebody
poses a real risk of harm to the British
public should removal be delayed Mike
can assure my honorable friend that
appropriate steps will be taken to
ensure that the public is properly
protected but as she is one of the
foremost members in this house uh in
tackling issues related to small boat
arrivals of course due to the particular
concerns of her constituents in Dover
I'm grateful to her
for tabling this amendment and look
forward to continuing to work with her
as we work through these challenges
a number of other government amendments
address the concerns raised at committee
stage by amongst others my honorable and
right honorable friends the members for
stone for devises for Middlesbrough
South and East Cleveland and South
Holland and the deepings
who rightly want to ensure that the
scheme as provided for in the bill was
as robust as possible it not open to
exploitation and abuse by those who seek
to frustrate removals
please take away I I just also like to
reciprocate if I may in my 39 years in
the house I have to say I haven't had
and the opportunity of the kind that's
been offered by the government on this
occasion for a really good proper robust
but nonetheless effective Dialogue on
these incredibly important matters that
I wanted to put on record my thanks to
the government for that
well I'm very grateful to my honorable
friend for uh those kind words and we we
value his expertise and knowledge and
commitment on on this issue and I think
he has made this bill a better and
stronger one more likely to succeed in
our objective which is to stop the boats
and to restore confidence to the public
it's always been Our intention that the
only claims that were delay removal are
the factual suspensive claims and
serious harm suspensive claims provided
for in the bill all over the legal
challenges whether rights-based claims
or otherwise would be non-suspensive
new Clause 22 put forward by my
honorable friend the member for devises
makes it crystal clear that not only
will any judicial reviews be
non-suspensive but it will also not be
open to the courts to Grant interim
remedies which have the effect of
blocking removals pending a substantive
decision on a judicial review and on a
similar thing new Clause 24 makes it
clear that any legal challenges relating
to a decision about a person's age are
also non-suspensive and through new
Clause 25 we're taking a power to make
regulations setting out the
circumstances in which it can be assumed
that someone who refuses to undergo a
scientific age assessment is an adult I
can assure the house that we will only
make such regulations once we're
satisfied that the scientific models are
sufficiently accurate to mean that
applying an automatic assumption will be
compatible with the EC HR and on this
question I particularly like to thank my
rightful friend the member for South
Holland and the deepings who has worked
closely with the government to achieve
our shared objective on the issue of
interim relief we're also replacing the
marker Clause relating to interim
measures indicated by the Strasbourg
Court as my writable friend the Home
Secretary indicated at second reading
the Strasbourg court is itself carrying
out a review of the rule 39 process at
the encouragement of a number of member
of States including ourselves and the
former deputy prime minister then the
Lord Chancellor and the current attorney
general have had constructive
discussions with the court about reform
including rule 39 but we can and should
do more new Clause 26 will confer a
discretion on the Home Secretary or any
other minister of the crown to be
exercised personally to suspend the duty
to remove a person where an interim
measure has been indicated on an
individual case the new Clause sets out
a non-exhaustive list of considerations
that the minister may have regard to
when considering the exercise of such
discretion in that case the minister
will be accountable to Parliament for
the exercise of this personal discretion
the government expects that the minister
will carefully consider the UK's
International obligations when deciding
whether to disapply the duty I'll give
way to the online little term for giving
way it seems to me that new Clause 26
effectively introduces a presumption
that the UK government will breach
international law when interim measures
are handed down in this Respect by the
court now in Strasbourg now home
secretary's already said on the face of
this bill that she can't certify that
it's compatible with the echr but she's
declined to give evidence to the Joint
Committee on human rights in order to
assist us in the legislative scrutiny of
this bill can the ministry explain to
the house why the Home Secretary is so
reluctant to come to the Joint Committee
to justify her her admission that this
bill is not compatible with the echr
the government believes that the bill is
compatible we we believe that there are
strong arguments and of course there
will be legal debate but uh if any
aspect of the bill were to be challenged
we look forward to defending it robustly
we take our treaty obligations I won't
give away a second time if I if I don't
mind to The Honorable lady because we
we've been very clear that we take our
treaty obligations seriously and with
respect to the ministerial discretion uh
in this clause
the set the Home Secretary or whichever
minister of the state exercise this
discretion would of course take those
obligations seriously and they would
judge the individual uh I will complain
it isn't in fact my right honorable
friend in effect asking this house
to give legislative sanction to at least
the possibility
that a minister of the crown will
deliberately disobey the international
law obligations of this country isn't
that really the effect of what what is
being asked
minister no as I've as I've already said
we take our treaty obligations very
seriously
and the minister exercising this
discretion would have to do so and this
power Woody or discretion would be
exercised highly judiciously and it
would ultimately be judged on the facts
and be very fact dependent
uh I'm not going to agree with normally
I will give away one last time that I
must I must make a minister
has always got the ability to ignore an
indication under rule 39 because there
is no obligation under the convention
for the government to heed them it is an
indication
why then does it need legislation
if what in fact is being not being asked
that this house should approve quite
consciously and deliberately a
deliberate
breach of our obligations under the
convention that that is the truth um the
minister could ignore it and it would be
a matter between states
but this provision invites this house to
give legislative authority to the
Minister doing that if she chooses to do
so isn't that the position
my rightful friend is correct in saying
that uh
rule 39 indications
uh are that and that there are
circumstances in which ministers have
chosen not to apply them uh a small
number but there are a number uh this uh
Clause does not mandate a minister to
ignore Rule 13 million uh indications it
says clearly for
to ensure that there is no doubt
whatsoever that the minister has the
discretion to do so it gives the
non-exhaustive list of reasons that they
should consider
and in doing so clearly as I've said a
number of occasions they would take
their treaty obligations very seriously
moving on as I've said the bill provides
for two kinds of suspensive claims and
sets out a fair but rigorous timetable
for the submission of any claims their
determination by the home office and any
appeals it's important that those who
receive a removal notice should be able
to receive appropriate legal advice to
help them to navigate the process and so
new Clause 20 accordingly makes
provision for legal aid I trust this
amendment at least uh will be welcomed
by The Honorable for Glasgow Central
given that it covers similar ground to
her own Clause 18. the provision of
legal aid will reduce the opportunities
for challenges and will speed up
removals
as regards serious harm suspenser claims
new Clause 17 augments the existing
Provisions in Clause 38 of the bill
which enables regulations to be made
about the meaning of serious and
irreversible harm for the purposes of
the bill we consider it important and
indeed helpful to the courts to provide
them with guidance as to what does or
does not amount to serious and
irreversible harm albeit that ultimately
the judgment will be for the upper
tribunal to be taken on a case-by-case
basis a new Clause 17 also makes it
clear that the serious and irreversible
harm must be imminent and foreseeable
which aligns to the test in the bill or
aligns the test in the bill much more
closely with Strasbourg practice
amendments 114 and 119 relate to foreign
National offenders in the nationality
and borders act 2022 we legislated to
disapply certain modern slavery
protections to fnos sentenced to a term
of imprisonment of 12 months or more and
to certain other categories of person
who present a real risk to public order
these amendments now introduce a
statutory presumption that the public
order disqualification applies to fnos
given an immediate custodial sentence of
any length
finally let me address new Clauses 19
and 23 a new schedule 1 which seek to
ensure that we have the necessary
broader powers to tackle illegal
migration the new schedule confers new
powers on immigration officers to search
for seize and retain mobile phones and
other electronic devices from illegal
migrants where it where it appears to an
immigration officer that they may
contain information relevant to the
discharge of their functions including a
criminal investigation
new Clause 19 will additionally put
Beyond doubt that credibility should be
damaged where a person who's made an
asylum or human rights-based claim
refuses to enable access to their mobile
phone or fails to produce or destroys
identity documents without reasonable
excuse and on this important change in
the law I pay particular tribute to my
honorable friend the member for Newbury
one of the most experienced members of
the house and immigration matters who
made this case very strongly
I'm not going to go I'll draw my remarks
to a close now Madam Deputy speaker I
won't detain the house by detailing the
other government amendments I summarize
these in a letter
I'll give way to it if members don't
mind I'll give way to the right
honorable League I'm very grateful to my
right honorable friend for giving way
and I wonder if he could comment on the
matter which has literally been brought
to my attention while he has been on his
feet which is a message from greater
Manchester police relating to their
program Challenger which is the program
they operate for dealing with serious
and organized crime and they have put
this urgent update out as a result of
the nationality and borders act 2022
changes came into effect in February 23
which had an immediate impact on
potential victims this has seen positive
first stage decisions drop from around
95 of all submissions to 18 of
submissions between February 20th and
March the 31st this means that four in
five potential victims are not able to
access immediate support from the
national modern slavery and human
trafficking victim care providers is my
right honorable friend as worried about
that as I am and if he is not worried is
it because he feels that the impact of
the national energy and borders Act is
already working in which case why does
he need modern slavery Provisions in
this bill
that well it's difficult for me to
comment on uh remarks that are read out
uh which I've known I haven't seen sight
of as frankly she she would not have
done when she was a home office Minister
either
um but but it is she and I have a
disagreement on the impact that modern
slavery is currently having on our
system but the evidence to me is very
clear that unfortunately and this was
never the intention of the framework
that's been created unfortunately there
is significant abuse and we see that in
particular in the number of individuals
who are coming forward with modern
slavery claims in the detained estate
when we're seeking to remove them from
the country these last minute claims
currently at 70 percent of individuals
that I'm afraid amongst other evidence
does show that we've got a serious
problem and we have to take action I'm
going to draw my remarks to a close now
because I think all members want to see
an opportunity for others I'm not going
to I'm not going to give way
man in depth is are not going away
because there's very limited amount of
times
um Madame Deputy speaker I've summarized
the other government amendments which
are more detailed technical nature in a
letter to The Honorable member for
aberravan and placed a copy in the
library of the house and stand ready to
address any particular points in the
winding up to debate uh if necessary for
now Madness speak I commend all of the
government amendments to the house and
look forward to the contributions from
other honorable members and we'll
respond to as many as I can at the end
of the debate
expensive claims and
question is that new Clause 17 be read a
second time Shadow Minister Stephen
killer well thank you very much Madam
Deputy speaker I'd like to start by
associating myself with the commons by
the immigration Minister about the
outstanding work that our armed forces
have done in Sudan and I wish all who
were there a speedy return home
I want to start by making one thing
absolutely clear Madame Deputy speaker
and it's a point with which I am sure
every member of this house agrees the
dangerous Channel Crossings Must Be
Stopped these extremely perilous
Journeys have tragically led to lives
being lost and the only people who
benefit from this trade and human misery
are the criminal Smuggler gangs and
people traffickers who are laughing all
the way to the bank at this government's
failure to arrest and prosecute them
labor has a comprehensive and workable
five-point plan which will defeat the
people Smugglers and fix our broken
Asylum system our plan is expressed
through the Amendments and new Clauses
that we have tabled to this bill and I
will speak to these in due course
but Madam Deputy speaker members
opposite opposite repeatedly state that
they wish to stop the dangerous Channel
Crossings but the fact is that they are
completely and utterly failing to do so
every single measure that ministers
announce turns out to either be an
expensive and unworkable headline
chasing gimmick or a policy that
succeeds only in making things worth
worse or indeed both and in the case of
this legislative sham that we're
debating today this bigger backlog bill
it is definitely both
Madam Deputy speaker under the
conservatives the channel Crossings have
skyrocketed from 299 in 2018 to 46 000
in 2022 and throughout this period
ministers have subjected the country to
a seemingly endless stream of
nonsensical proposals which have all
been given pride of place on the front
pages of the Daily Mail and the Daily
Telegraph only to be swiftly consigned
to the Dustbin of History where they
belong
Madam Deputy speaker in order for a
deterrent to be effective it has to be
credible and of course your credibility
is severely diminished every time you
fail to follow through on a commitment
that you've made so let's take a quick
Canter through some of the posturing and
empty threats that this shambles of a
government has made over the last few
years
they told us that the British Coast
Guard would be instructed to push back
dinghies in the channel which would have
breached the law of the sea and
potentially led to further deaths of
refugees and innocent children then they
said they were going to build a giant
wave machine in the English Channel I
mean I don't know where you'd find a
wave machine around here given that the
conservatives have closed down most of
England's swimming pools although I
suppose it's possible the Prime Minister
might have a spare one back at his place
and then they said they were going to
fly Asylum Seekers to Ascension Island 4
000 miles away and they even fantasized
about sending them to Papua New Guinea
which is literally on the other side of
the planet
and that brings us to their latest
cunning plan they went to Kigali and
they paid 140 million pounds for a press
release and 12 months later they have
managed to send more home secretaries to
Rwanda than they have Asylum Seekers
Madam Deputy speaker you'd you could be
forgiven for finding all of this quite
comical but the fact is that it's deadly
serious because a vast amount of
taxpayers money is being squandered on a
profoundly unethical policy that is
designed to fail on its own terms
because even if the Rwanda scheme does
get up and running which the government
admits is unlikely to happen until at
least March 2024 the Rwandan government
has refused to commit to taking more
than around one or two percent of the
those who arrive here on small boats
we're talking hundreds of removals
rather than the thousands per year that
might have a chance of deterring Asylum
Seekers from crossing the channel
so it will fail to stop the small boat
Channel's Crossings because if you've
experienced personal tragedy fought your
way across continents and handed your
life savings to a people Smuggler so
that you can endanger your own life
crossing the channel then a one percent
chance of being sent through Rwanda is
simply not going to represent a level of
risk that you might be averse to
you I will be right
on the point of the rubalde scheme apart
from paying 150 million pounds or maybe
deporting 200 people we also under the
tree under the agreement have to take
people back from Rwanda as well
my honorable friend has made a very
important point which I would also use
as a as a prompt to talk about the
Israel scheme so of course Israel and
Rwanda did a deal what happened with
that scheme every single one of the
people that were sent from Israel to
Rwanda had left Rwanda within a matter
of weeks and were on their way back to
Europe so it's a very expensive way of
giving people a round trip and I would
not recommend it as a deterrent
and then just to add to the general
sense that the government has lost the
plot we had the bizarre and frankly
appalling spectacle of the Home
Secretary jetting down to Rwanda with a
carefully vetted gaggle of journalists
in order to indulge in a photo shoot
that was akin to a visit Rwanda tourist
promo now I may have missed something
Madam Deputy speaker but I thought the
idea was to deter the channel crossings
by using Rwanda as a threat I'm not
quite sure how that tallies with the
Home Secretary likening Kigali to the
Garden of Eden one minute Rwanda is the
perfect place imaginable to rebuild your
life the next the threat of getting sent
there is being deployed as a deterrent
it's a truly farcical State of Affairs
but it's also of central importance to
what we're debating today because the
entire bill is predicated on the
government being able to remove those
who arrive here on small boats to a safe
Third Country and right now Rwanda is
the only safe Third Country they've got
so the fact that the Rwanda plan is
unworkable unaffordable and unethical
renders this entire Bill unworkable
unaffordable and unethical
because this was a an issue he raised
before and I raised at the earlier
stages of the bill when the home Affairs
select committee went to Calais in
January and we met all the people
involved in patrolling the beaches and
the local officials they told us that
when the Rwanda scheme was announced
there was a surge in migrants
approaching the French authorities
because they didn't want to end up on a
plane to Rwanda about staying in France
so there was a deterrent effect the
trouble is it hasn't actually started it
yet but if it did it would have an
impact and that's the point
well I think the honorable gentleman for
his intervention I'm not sure I follow
the logic of it because he said there
was a deterrent effect but it hasn't
started yet which suggests to me that
there has not been a deterrent effect
and if we look at the numbers the the
it's these Channel Crossings continue to
sky rocket so I think what matters to
this house is results and outcomes and
as things stand there is no evidence
whatsoever that it has acted as a
deterrent
Madam Deputy speaker this bigger backlog
bill is rotten to its very core because
it prevents the Home Secretary from
considering those who arrive here on
small boats as Asylum Seekers and
instead obliges her to detain and remove
them but there's nowhere to detain them
and there's nowhere to remove them to
either we already have 50 000 Asylum
Seekers and around 400 hotels costing
the taxpayer and eye-watering six
million pounds every single day and on
average each Asylum Seeker is waiting a
staggering 450 days for a decision the
backlog now stands at 166
000 more than eight times larger than
when labor left office in 2010 when it
was it stood at just under 19 000. and
incidentally I'm still waiting for the
Prime Minister and the minister opposite
to apologize to the house and correct
the record on that point
today is a report stage around detention
I listen carefully to what the minister
said about unaccompanied children and
detaining them but I also wanted to ask
my honorable friend his views about
detaining children families with
children and pregnant women this house
has made very clear in the past its view
about safeguards being required for
detention of vulnerable groups as I've
just described does my honorable friend
think that we need to think again now
about pregnant women and children with
families and detention
well I thank my honorable friend for for
that excellent intervention I I think
she's absolutely right to highlight this
issue and she has tabled a compelling
Amendment on this issue she's aware that
members on both sides fought very hard
for these legal limits so she rightly
pointed out and you know when we're
talking about the Detention of pregnant
women I think removing those limits now
and Paving the way for vulnerable
individuals to be detained individually
it's it's it's morally wrong it's
wrong-headed it's deeply
counterproductive and I have not heard
any argument to justify it from
ministers
Now new figures reveal that this bigger
backlog bill could end up putting an
extra 50 000 people into permanent
taxpayer-funded accommodation this year
with hotel costs rising to over 13
million pounds a day which is over 4
billion pounds a year during a cost of
living crisis and this is because
according to the government's own
forecasts 53 000 who cross on small
boats will be classed as inadmissible
without any Prospect of being removed
and what's particularly astonishing is
that they made the same mistake last
year by including similar
inadmissibility Provisions in the
nationality and borders act the result a
cost of 400 million pounds to the
taxpayer in just six months with only 21
people returned to their country of
origin Madam Deputy speaker this
bungling government just keeps doubling
down on its own incompetence the more
posturing they do the more small boats
we see the longer they govern the longer
the Asylum backlog grows and the more
our constituents will ask themselves
with record high immigration figures and
a record high Asylum backlog are our
borders more or less secure under the
Tories
I thank you on a friend forgiving way
I completely understand why the minister
did not want to give way despite saying
that he would do on this particular
issue but he raises the question of
people being in hotels does he also
agree with me that this government needs
to be honest with its own backbenches
about the statutory instruments that try
to slip out at the end of the last
session that will remove the Licensing
Laws from places for houses of multiple
occupancy for Asylum Seekers that will
presumably prevent their local
authorities from refusing to license
those places it will also have the
consequence of meaning that we no longer
require places where we're expecting
families and pregnant women and small
children to live to have fire alarms or
smoke alarms or indeed running water
does he agree with me this gun needs to
be honest about how awful it wishes to
treat Asylum Seekers and how it's going
to avoid local authorities being part of
that conversation I I thank my honorable
friend for that powerful intervention
and and she's absolutely right we're
talking here about basic standards of
decency and humanity and houses of
multiple occupancy need to be properly
regulated they need a basic flaw in
terms of certification registration
safety health and safety and
particularly when we're looking we're
talking here about families
um so it's she's absolutely right and I
do think that the the government would
um really should consider being more
transparent and straightforward on on
that point
fortunately we on these benches do care
about secure borders and we will clear
up the mess by delivering a firm fair
and well-managed system that will stop
the dangerous Channel Crossings because
we know that good government is not
about chasing headlines Madame Deputy
speaker it's about common sense hard
graft and quiet diplomacy and these are
the qualities that underpin our new
Clauses and amendments to this bill each
other minister of giving way I I
interviewed Michelle Minister I'm at
committee stage and I found out that
apparently there's a cap or labor party
supported cap for safe and legal Roots
which was news to me at the time as I
should have Minister had any time to
think about what that cat level would be
but also bearing in mind how many people
would like to try and get to our country
what the approach would be to those who
had failed in their application but had
still traveled here illegally and got
here would the labor party feature
potential labor doesn't be open to
deporting those individuals well the the
cap has to be determined in consultation
with local authorities and with
Parliament uh that is absolutely right
in terms of removals of course what you
need is a processing system that
actually works so that you can get to a
decision and people who are from safe
countries that should be removed they
need to be swiftly removed from our
country and those that are genuine
Asylum Seekers should be granted leave
to remain so that they can get on with
their lives and we can start to clear up
the abject mess that this government has
made of of our Asylum system
the first part of our five-point plan is
to repurpose the funds that are
currently being wasted on the money for
nothing Rwanda plan and to redirect
those funds into a new Elite
cross-border 100 strong police force
that will relentlessly pursue the
ruthless criminal smuggling gangs
Upstream the latest 500 million pound
payment that the British government has
made to the French government will be
having some effect on reducing the
crossings but the reality is that we
will not succeed if we're focusing all
our efforts on the hundreds of
kilometers of French Coastline where
resources are bound to be spread very
thin we also need sophisticated
operations with the British authorities
working with EU member states europol
Interpol and frontex to tackle The Gangs
Upstream our new Clause 16 therefore
instructs the government to lay before
Parliament a framework for a 12-month
pilot cooperation agreement with those
governments and agencies that can do
just that in order to secure the
prosecution and conviction of persons
involved in facilitating illegal entry
to the United Kingdom from neighboring
countries turning to new Clause 16 this
also incorporates the uh excuse me
nuclear 16 which I was talking to also
incorporates the second part of our plan
securing a returns agreement with the
European Union this is essential since
the party opposite botched the brexit
negotiations and Britain left the Dublin
convention which had provided agreements
on returns the number of Channel
Crossings has gone up by an astonishing
2 400 percent for every one person
crossing the channel in a small boat in
2019 24 cross now Madam Deputy speaker
there are three vitally important points
to make with regards to getting a
returns deal First International
challenges require International
Solutions second we need an agreement
with our nearest Neighbors which must
include returns and third we will only
strike a returns deal with the European
Union if we bring something into the
negotiation and that should include a
proper plan for capped safe and legal
routes for bona fide Asylum Seekers
located in Mainland Europe we suggest
that Britain prioritizes unaccompanied
children with family in the UK and our
new Clause 14 reflects this
so I I think the honorable gentleman was
first I will come to The Honorable I I
just would uh like the Donald Jensen
reflect on the fact that when President
mackerel made his assertions about
returns back to France actually the
European Union the following day said
they weren't going to count on us any
such proposals they just simply do not
agree for returns and furthermore of
course France itself is not a place
where people will associate with a
persecution or threats or irreversible
harm so what what is his argument all
about
this is about a negotiation we clearly
have to do a returns deal it's an
important part of the deterrent effect
you don't get a returns deal unless you
have uh something on the table and
that's where we believe there should be
a clear link between a policies on safe
and legal routes uh as a way of getting
a clear position uh in terms of
negotiations with the European Union the
reality is that this is the only
deterrent effect that really is going to
work you you're dealing with people that
have risked their lives come have fought
their way across Europe are prepared to
spend their life savings on paying
people Smugglers to cross the channel
you're not going to deter them unless
they know that there's a returns deal in
place and that's one of the reasons why
the doubling convention worked it acted
as a deterrent the reason that then what
how else can you explain that the
numbers have gone through the roof since
we left the Dublin convention
it's simple I'm grateful because this is
just nonsense in the last year that we
were covered by the doubling convention
before the pandemic struck we applied to
the EU for eight and a half thousand
returns under that returns agreement
only 105
were granted 1.2 so this is completely
nonsense it didn't work when we were in
the EU and he's now expecting to Magic
out some agreement which they're not
going to give us anyway so stop
misleading the house about those figures
I find this response bizarre because
there's there's some very simple facts
which are we left the Dublin convention
and since we left the Dublin convention
the number of Small Boat Crossings have
gone through the roof it's not rocket
science Madam Deputy speaker it's a
simple fact of mathematics and and the
point is that you cannot solve an
international problem without
International cooperation you have to
recognize that there is a flow of ref
Asylum Seekers coming across the
European Union the idea that we just say
to the EU you can take them all and
we're not going to take any it's for the
birds it is fantasy politics and I'm
just quite stunned that members opposite
don't seem to understand that very
simple political fact I will actually I
remember if if the right honorable
member of maidenhead doesn't mind me
mentioning her when she when she was
prime minister the first letter that she
wrote in trying to trigger article 50 to
the European Union said that we wanted
to have a a security treaty with the
European Union that's what I would
dearly love us to have I think it's one
of the great flaws out of how we've left
the European Union that we haven't ended
up with that surely this should be part
of that security treaty so that we have
better relations with Interpol with
Europe role with front text with all the
and we have proper sharing of
information so that anybody who is
arriving in the UK we know all their
details isn't that where we need to go
The Honorable gentleman is absolutely
right we know from our long period of
being in the European Union that in
order to get a deal with the European
Union you it has to be a quid pro quo
there has to be a negotiation based on a
grown-up conversation about the
challenge that you need to tackle and
how to tackle it and a security an
all-encompassing security agreement
could be a very good way to open that
door because of course the European
Union knows that the United Kingdom is a
very important security partner for all
sorts of reasons so I agree with him
entirely on that very strategic Point
that he's made
so while we support government new
Clause 8 on safe and legal routes we
believe that it should be linked to
securing a returns deal with the
European Union and as I said our
approach is based on hard draft common
sense and quiet diplomacy and we would
urge the government to start thinking
and acting in the same vein our third
commitment is that labor will fix the
problems with current resettlement
programs this includes the broken Afghan
schemes and our new Clause 21 instructs
the government to report every three
months on progress or lack of in meeting
its own Target in terms of supporting
those loyal to Britain Afghans who
sacrifice so much to protect our service
people and to stand up for our liberal
values in Afghanistan
all resettlement routes need to of
course be properly controlled and
managed and they therefore cannot be
unlimited but they do also need to work
fourthly Labor's long-term International
Development strategy will include
tackling the root causes of migration
Upstream through increased humanitarian
assistance and greater emphasis on
conflict prevention and resolution
programs this is slightly beyond the
focus of this bill but an important
aspect of migration policy and a lesson
that needs to be learned from
Afghanistan in relation to Sudan of
course which was mentioned earlier on
early on if you cut Aid and you cut the
right kind of Aid you will end up
increasing the challenges around the
dangerous Channel Crossings and you hurt
British values and interests excuse me
our comprehensive plan will also fix
what is perhaps the conservative's most
astonishing failure of basic governance
the failure to clear the backlog is
truly staggering that just 13 of small
boat Asylum claims are being processed
within five years and it's deeply
troubling that while around half of the
huge 166 000 backlog is down to Small
Boat Crossings another 80 000 has built
up organically under the conservative
since 2010. this is no coincidence home
office decision making has collapsed in
2013 the conservatives downgraded Asylum
decision makers to junior staff hired
literally going from a Saturday job one
minute to making life or death decisions
the next no wonder this resulted in
worse decisions often overturned on
appeal and it's deeply troubling that
the staff's attrition rate in 2022 in
these teams stood at an astonishing 46
percent and there is little Prospect of
improvement Madame Deputy speaker Given
Home given that home office statistics
published on Monday show that this year
the number of decision makers has
actually decreased so let's begin the
incompetence and indifference of a
consecutive home secretaries since 2010
that have brought the basic functions of
government to a grinding Halt and during
this cost of living crisis the British
taxpayer is paying the price
our new Clause 10 therefore sets out how
the government should get on with
Expediting Asylum processing for the
countries that are listing listed in the
schedule of this bill if an applicant
has no right to Asylum in the UK they
should be removed safely and swiftly to
the safe country from which they have
come such as Albania
that's a new Clause 10 our new Clause 13
instructs the Home Secretary to publish
a report every three months on the
progress that she's making on clearing
the backlog the backlog crisis is every
oh
I'm sorry to interrupt the ministers
follow and I wholeheartedly support him
as we have time and time again with
regard to the criticisms of the
government's lack of processing of cases
including the lack of Staffing Resources
on new Clause 10 where so the proposal
is for an expedited Asylum process could
he reassure me that there'll be no
lessening of the legal rights of Asylum
Seekers no lessening of access to legal
representation and no listening of the
application of international human
rights treaties and conventions under
this process
I thank my honorable friend for that
intervention and absolutely uh the
proposal is that there are a number of
countries which have very low Grant
rates and that must therefore be where
we triage and put them into a category
where the processing can be expedited
however all of the processing must be
done on an individual case-by-case basis
in line with our treaty obligations you
cannot have block definitions of any
particular category of Asylum seeker and
of course that's one of the main issues
around the legality of this bill and
that includes access to Legal Aid so I
can absolutely reassure him on that
point we have to get the balance right
between the efficiency and effectiveness
of dealing with the backlog that has to
be based on triaging on giving much more
support and upgrading the staff in the
home office but it must also be excuse
me Madam the speaker it must also be
underpinned by the provisions that he
refers to
um
and of course the the return on
investment for improving the quality of
decision making uh would be rapid and
substantial because quicker processing
means fewer Asylum seekers in hotels
which brings me to our amendments on
accommodation for Asylum Seekers bad
decisions on the location of
accommodation means that the process
then slows down due to Legal challenges
and the whole system gets even more
clogged up it would be far better to
consult local authorities early in the
process and our new Clause 9 instructs
the government to do just that I was
rather disappointed by the fact that the
foreign secretary and The Honorable
member for Dorset among others failed to
join us in the division lobbies during
committee stage when we voted for this
equivalent clause
I'm aware that they have pushed back
against ham-fisted ministers trying to
Steamroller them on this matter and I
also know that they've sided with their
local conservative councils against
their own government but they are
certainly not the only members on the
benches opposite who have urged the home
office to do better on this point and of
course all accommodation must be valued
for money as our new Clause 11 indicated
indicates we can't keep having private
companies making these huge markups at
the expense of the taxpayer
I think I think the Shelley minister of
giving away
um just say for instance this quiet
diplomacy wasn't as successful as he
hoped and actually a lot of his returns
agreements didn't actually materialize
and actually all of these people who did
it arrive here illegally actually were
green lighted if the labor government
was ever in charge would it ever at any
point be any any policy whatsoever to
deport to a safe Third Country
well as I've just pointed out we're
proposing for example a fast track for
people from safe countries we absolutely
are of the view that people lose Asylum
uh claims are not uh successfully
legitimate should be as rapidly and
safely sent back to their country of
origin so I'm I I hope I've understood
the the point that honorable gentleman
was making I'm not quite sure what it
was
um Madam Deputy speaker honorable and
right honorable members on both sides of
the house have raised concerns about the
way in which this bill will undermine
our ability to crack down on Modern
slavery and we do have to ask why it is
that the Prime Minister has taken the
attitude towards trafficked women and
young girls being sold as sex slaves and
so accommodating to terrorists and
criminals on the other hand you just
need to look at his tweet of the 7th of
March threatening victims of modern
slavery with deportation
it was disgraceful and now his
government's Amendments 114-116 have
made it even harder for victims to come
forward it will be held up by I'm afraid
The Pimps and the traffickers to
threaten their victims two former
independent anti-slavery Commissioners
Sarah Thornton and Kevin Hyland recently
warned that this bill will devastate
modern slavery protections and it's a
gift to criminals all of us in this
house know that this bill is a
traffickers charter and then just look
at the prime minister's shocking record
on deporting foreign criminals
astonishingly 19 Terror suspects are
living in taxpayer-funded British hotels
because the government has failed to
remove them Labor's new Clause 15 places
a duty on the Secretary of State to
remove suspected terrorists who've
entered the country illegally or
consider the imposition of terrorism
prevention and investigation measures
upon them deportations of criminals have
fallen off a cliff since the
conservatives came to power in 2010 they
plummeted by 66 percent to five thousand
a year before the pandemic and to just
2100 in 2021 this is an insult to
victims and it again proves what we all
know labor is tough on crime and tough
on the causes of crime but under the
conservatives criminals of never had it
so good Madam Deputy speaker the
minister for immigration was appointed
to his position as the moderate Voice
who would curb the more fanatical
Tendencies of his boss but that simply
has not happened instead it appears that
he's either been kidnapped by the hard
right of his party or he's willingly
hitched his wagon to them because he
thinks that's why the wind is blowing
but the minister is not alone because
his friend the Prime Minister also
appears to have caved into the Home
Secretary and the trumpian faction that
she leads he's caved into her by adding
of government new Clauses 22 and 26 to
this bill thereby completely torpedoing
his own negotiations with the European
Court of Human Rights it really is quite
extraordinary that conservative Prime
Ministers never seem to learn from the
fate of their predecessors the more you
appease the extremists the more they
demand the prime minister is weak and
he's been played this weakness did for
his predecessors and ultimately it will
also do for him but arguably the most
shocking of this whole sorry tale Madam
Deputy speakers this concern
government's contempt for cash payer tax
apart aside from losing billions to
fraudsters during the pandemic dishing
out overpriced contracts to their mates
for unusable PPE and crashing the
economy to the tune of 30 billion pounds
the government's Asylum policy stand out
as a prime example of ministers
scattering taxpayer money to the Four
Winds and receiving absolutely nothing
in return chasing headlines while buying
failure there are so many vitally
important questions to be answered why
for instance has the government failed
to publish an impact assessment for
example do ministers have any idea of
the increase in detention capacity that
will be required because of this bill
the Home Secretary was completely unable
to answer this simple question during
her car crash of an interview on the
radio this morning and how much will
these additional detention places cost
how much will the government pay Rwanda
per Asylum seeker and how much will each
flight cost we still don't know the
answer to that question one year after
the 140 million pounds was given our
constituent deserve to know as these
decisions impact directly on their
communities and on the state of our
public finances it's outrageous the
government's not providing an IO tour of
information about the impact of a bill
with such huge financial and Community
impact implications so we're bound to
ask Madam Deputy speaker what are they
afraid of if they truly believe that
this bill is it will succeed
in achieving its objectives then surely
they would happily have published the
impact assessment well before second
reading and they would have been
delighted to stand at that dispatch box
to defend it but of course there is
another possibility Madame Deputy
speaker which is the ministers have not
even attempted to assess the impact of
this bigger backlog bill because they're
utterly terrified of what they would
reveal if they did they're terrified of
seeing the cost of their own
incompetence they're horrified by the
thought of being transparent because
transparency reveals the truth and the
truth is that this bill will just make
everything worse it will boost the
profits of the people Smugglers it will
add tens of thousands to the backlog it
will add hundreds of millions to the
hotel build it will tarnish British
Britain's reputation as a country that
upholds the international rules-based
order it will further inflame Community
frustration and tension and it will add
to the desperate misery of those who are
seeking Sanctuary from persecution and
violence now many honorable members on
the benches opposite agree with every
word of what I've just said and I would
urge them to support our new Clauses and
to join us in the no Lobby when we vote
against this deeply damaging and
counterproductive bill this evening
thank you madam Dr speaker
there you go so we've had some very long
opening speeches and I've got over 20 uh
people wishing to contribute to the
debate
um that means that if everybody was to
get in everybody would need to be about
six minutes if not less
we will prioritize those who have
um amendments down but that is just my
guidance for the minute because we've
also got the SNP spokesperson to come in
Surrey and Duncan Smith uh Madam Deputy
speaker I'm grateful and I speak to the
amendment in my name and that of my
honorable wagonal friends Amendment four
which essentially uh uh is about Clause
21 however since then I realized that
the government has got a new amendment
in which is 95 and I'm afraid that makes
quite a lot of what trying to achieve
with our Amendment almost impossible to
deliver but I will go through the
purpose of our Amendment and then deal
with with the new amendment by the
government so first of all a lot of this
is uh shadowed by the already existing
nationality and borders act which we
still wait to see what the impact of
that is on a lot of this and there's
some clear evidence already that it is
tightening up in the areas that the
government now wants to tighten up here
in this bill when it comes to the cause
of those who have been suffering from
Modern slavery and therefore I question
the necessity of these these issues in
here about modern slavery at all first
and forth but frankly I won't want to do
too Broadband I want to focus on this
quite carefully the the problem is
I think that the government I hope May
recognize him my honorable friend
mentioned that that was the the general
direction of his thinking at the moment
and I really hope that is the case that
there are now unintended consequences of
what they've tried to do in this bill
when it comes to the changes they're
making uh to uh which concerns Clause 21
and without our Amendment uh we'll
damage it now it's interesting that my
right honorable friend uh got up and
intervened with some very new uh
evidence that the police are now saying
that the effect of this even though it's
not in is to uh is to concern people who
might well give evidence that would lead
therefore to the prosecution and
conviction of those who are guilty of
trafficking can I just say I think the
whole purpose of this at the end of the
day is that we get the traffickers we
prosecute them and we put them inside
that is one of the deterrents about
other traffickers doing the business and
and and I understand the purpose of the
bill is to stop the business model of
the traffic workers so this fits with
that the problem is the Counterpoint of
that is that that Clause 21 seems to
move in the opposite direction of that
and actually now is beginning to
discourage the idea of those giving
evidence and the two reasons for that is
and it's very important here to remind
everybody because it gets confused
doesn't it really human trafficking is
distinct from people smuggling you know
we tend to blur the edges of this uh
human trafficking is about people
against their will who are brought to
this location or whilst in the UK
actually then themselves are abused by
all the issues that have been talked
about earlier on the reality is uh
there's against their will they do not
wish to do it and we need the evidence
of that categorically so it's dealing
with the trafficking side rather than
the people smuggling that I'm really
concerned about it and I remember a
majority of the potential victims
referred to by the end to the nrm are
exploited in the UK in full or in part
and mostly those are non-uk Nationals
but there are UK Nationals caught up in
that as well so this is not the majority
of these cases are not relevant to those
coming across on the boat uh it they're
here they've been traffic they're here
and they're now involved in modern
slavery and they are prepared possibly
to give evidence to the police for that
regard could be sexual exploitation it
could be criminal exploitation when I
was Secretary of State for work and
pensions we saw evidence of that with
people brought over to State their
claims to benefits and then they would
disappear off trafficked into brothels
and various other aspects so I I want to
say importantly we need to distinguish
that between that and the and the issue
of the boats
and so those are likely to have arrived
in the UK legally within the terms of
this bill whether by small vote Lorry or
with legal stain through deceptions such
as false documents including deception
by their exploiter instead of being
given temporary protection in the UK
these victims will now if 21 exist and
subsequently now 95 is the amendment
these victims will now be subjected to
removal and attention under this bill
and denied access to the statutory
30-day recovery period of support for
modern slavery victims victims will be
driven even further underground which is
our fear and those who deal with them by
the fear of deportation and Trapped In
the Arms of their abusers why would that
be the case the answer to that is very
simple everyone looks at the the wording
even of 21 we see straight away that the
shift in balance is very clear that is
to say that it is in the view of the
government of the Secretary of State
whether or not they are going to give
evidence or they're giving evidence that
relevant so that's left to their
judgment and then we get the government
Amendment 95 which I am really concerned
about because it shifts the whole
rationale in the opposite direction so
instead of there being a judgment about
that even under 21 it's now clear that
the pro the premise of everything that
the secretary of state will make as
decision making is now reversed so this
is very clear the secretary state must
assume for the purpose of subsection 3B
which is in uh Clause 21 that it is not
necessary for the person to be present
in the United Kingdom to provide the
cooperation in question unless the
Secretary of State considers that there
are compelling circumstances which
require the person to be present in the
United Kingdom for that purpose and the
point I raised earlier on and in doing
that the secretary of state must have
regard to guidance issued by the
secretary of state that looks to me like
a bit of a closed advice section which
will come up with the same uh same
decision at the end of the day so that
is now to be amended into existing
Clause 21 which we already had concerns
about which our Amendment for was to
give protections and our Amendment four
was to add to three section three this
other uh element a a which is that it
that if the executive state to make the
decision either the relevant
exploitation that has taken place in the
UK in the individual is exempt that is
critical but even that now it seems
becomes a problem because subsequently
the the reality is that secretary state
must assume it's not necessary which
makes it even more difficult to exempt
them from that position I raise that
point with my right honorable friend of
the front bench I think it's very
important now that we look at this
carefully and it may well be necessary
and I think it will be necessary and the
other place to rectify this because that
sends a terrible signal a terrible
signal to anybody who has been exploited
they will be told that by the way by the
traffickers don't worry they're going to
kick you out regardless what's the point
of even helping give evidence because
we'll get you on the other side if you
finger us that's what's going to happen
I give way to London
because despite his best efforts and and
I mean here's a model of clarity on this
it's still like trying to knit fog and
doesn't the fact that we're dealing here
with an amendment that he has brought
which has subsequently been affected by
an amendment to the original bill by the
government illustrate the total
inadequacy of trying to deal with a bill
like this in this way
well it's it's a concern because we've
got clashing amendments you know that
that is the point in a way of this uh
debate to rectify that we haven't got a
lot of time to do it uh so he'll forgive
me if I attentively nod in his Direction
but at the same time pursue my own
purposes it's not going to try and keep
this quite narrow I want to I don't want
to go wide because there are concerns
about other people wishing to speak so
this amendment of ours uh Amendment four
and why is it needed it's needed because
victims of modern slavery uh experience
in Humane torture and abuse they're
deprived of their Liberty and uh their
dignity they are exploited and abused on
British soil whether UK citizens or
foreign Nationals they deserve clearly
care to recover and we can't leave them
subject to that exploitation and the key
that I keep coming back to is victims uh
the in this category hold the key to the
prosecution of the very traffickers that
we're after I think we shouldn't lose
sight of that and if the inadvertent
result of these changes to the bill and
the bill itself is that they now are
fearful of coming forward to give
evidence partly because the the
presumption is that they should go and
leave the country and the second part of
that is they don't have enough time to
feel settled and protected to be able to
give that evidence of the combination of
those two things will mean that the
police and I think they know that and my
right humble friend has quoted from a
police statement that will reduce the
prosecutions that will damage our case
and will act as a as an opponent as it
were of the idea of sending the message
to traffickers that your game is up and
all the evidence shows that with
appropriate constant consistent support
more victims engage with investigations
and prosecutions providing the Vital
Information that brings criminals to
justice but support needs to come first
to create that stability because
otherwise they will not feel safe and if
they don't feel safe and if we put
ourselves in their situation we wouldn't
give evidence either if we think the
next stage that you're going to is
you're going to go out and the uh your
your traffickers will catch you when you
uh when you leave the country your
families or whoever's being abused at
the same time becomes a problem
so it gets harder to have convictions
and my uh I'm pleased that my right old
friend on the front bench uh did accept
that there may be consequences I think
we need to go further than the may but
there are consequences as a result of
the legislation that exists here and I
don't believe that the government wants
to see uh victims of modern slavery uh
being trafficked I don't think they want
to see this damaging the modern slavery
act I think that there is somehow in
Castle in the in the minds of those in
the home office a genuine dislike of
this legislation and a wish to blame it
for uh excesses but there is no evidence
of that even when they come over on the
boats only six percent of those who
actually claim
to be uh victims of modern slavery only
six percent of them are the result of
the numbers coming off of the boat so
first and foremost uh it's it's a case
that there isn't a huge great swell but
the second thing is the the uh the the a
borders bill that has preceded this has
now tightened up on all the elements
that they have to bring to show that
that is the case so it's already Tighter
and I suspect will lead to even fewer
cases already so the question mark
exists what is the point of putting
these these elements into this bill
because they're already coming through
in the previous bill and we still
haven't seen the effect of it so what we
are putting at risk here is the
prosecution first and foremost of all of
those traffickers and bringing them to
justice for something which is almost
certainly not going to happen and if it
did happen there is plenty of scope for
that evidence to come forward for there
to be subsequent to work through
statutory instruments if necessary but I
don't believe that will be the case and
the reality is that it is impossible for
people I'm told endlessly that people
will come come through and and give
false claims but let me remind everybody
that referrals can only be made by
official First Responders expect the
person is a victim first and foremost
and in 2022 49 of referrals were made by
government agencies ironic isn't it
really that it was the government
themselves that decided they were
victims so this idea that any person can
come forward and just suddenly say I'm a
victim and therefore I'm going to get
all this time it's not that the test of
evidence is very tough and I must say
also that remember this amendment of
ours is about those who are trafficked
and abused here in the UK so that means
the evidence Base is almost certainly
going to be incredibly strong because
it's based around what we know existing
here in the UK I understand it's
difficult when people are trafficked
from abroad but here these are
people in the UK and their evidence is
clear for all of us to see so under the
changes made to the interim statutory
guidance on Thursday January 2023 which
is again we we've yet to see the full
effects of that the threshold for a
positive reasonable grounds decision has
been raised to require objective
evidence of exploitation so again my
question is
this is a an unnecessary element of this
bill completely because we have yet to
see the effect already of the previous
act that came through and I believe that
is already having effect and the police
believe that is the case too which is
the other point so I'm going to
establishment
complete what I call it because others
want to speak I just simply want to say
we should proceed with caution when it
comes to modern day slavery I for one am
deeply proud of what we did and what my
right honorable friend brought through
because it deals with those who are
victims people who cannot speak for
themselves that are being uh used and
abused by others and we were the first
country in the world to do it and others
have followed suit we need to send the
right signals about this and I think the
problem with this uh bill right now is
it's unnecessarily now targeting a group
of people that are not the problem that
themselves will suffer and ironically we
will fail as a as a as a government
through the home Affairs end of it
because the police simply won't be able
to get those prosecutions so in every
grounds this is wrong and I have to say
that their new Amendment uh uh 95 is a
disastrous attempt to make it almost
impossible for anyone to feel confident
in the country before they give evidence
and I really really ask the government
before we make a decision about whether
mood to make it very clear at the end of
this debate that they will take this
away and they will genuinely generally
look to see what those unintended
consequences are now coming together to
become and make sure they make that case
to us
a certain piece spokesperson Allison
thank you very much Mr deputy secure our
eyes to move the amendment standing in
my name and those of my honorable
colleagues and it's interesting
following the honorable gentleman for
tingford mood for green and I hope very
much that given the concerns he's
outlined about this bill that will be
joining us in the in the lobbies later
on because I don't expect he's going to
get the assurances he hopes for from the
minister
this illegal migration Bill remains an
affront to human decency and her
obligations to her fellow human beings
it rips up hard one international
protections and is in breach of the
European convention and human rights the
refugee convention
the Council of Europe's convention in
actions against trafficking in the human
beings in the UN convention on the
rights of the child Scotland's children
and young people's commissioner has said
that the illegal migration Bill
represents a direct assault on the
concept of universal reality of Human
Rights and the rule of law organizations
have lined up to condemn it from the
unhcr Liberty Amnesty International
Trade unions and medical bodies it seeks
to turn ships captains and train drivers
into border guards and it creates a
subclass of people in Immigration limbo
forever
this Refugee ban bill is based on myths
mischiefs and the myopic pursuit of
clicks and tabloid headlines there is no
evidence no evidence whatsoever to
support the wild claims made by the Home
Secretary and her acolytes the bill will
not meet its stated aims but it will
cost lives and it fails to revealed safe
and legal Roots it will cause Mr Deputy
speaker Untold suffering it diminishes
the UK and the eyes of the world and it
Yanks and the thread that will unravel
Refugee protections across the world it
delivers people trafficked back into the
hands of those who would exploit them
and the immigration Minister this
morning descended yet further in his
article in conservative home speaking of
those with different Lifestyles and
values cannibalizing compassion Mr
Deputy speaker it's not a dog whistle
it's a fog horn the process by which
this government has brought forward the
illegal migration room the legal
vibration bill is an insult to democracy
and to this house rushed through without
a full committee stage no evidence
sessions no evidence whatsoever from the
government about the things that they
have put forward swedes swedes of
government amendments brought forward
today in haste are not yet even an
impact station impact assessment even at
this very very late stage that is
unacceptable that we are being asked
about on something without an impact
assessment I might have a friend for uh
Cameron old because I think I can tell
he has requested an impact to say that's
umpteen times in this house and Via an
FY request and nothing has yet been
forced forthcoming and I know the
honorable member for Bristol West has
also been tireless in pursuing this for
the bill and it's Testament really to
this government's dog a division of
scrutiny and not to their lack of effort
that this has been fruitless
Mr Deputy speaker we as members of
parliament in this house are guarantors
of Rights the snp's amendment 45 seeks
to hold the UK government to its
International obligation so utterly
bizarre and reprehensible that we even
have to put an amendment to ensure this
and to attempt to have the provisions of
the bill line up with convention rates
the refugee can be interested in the
European convention and accident against
Trafford in the U.N convention the
rights of the child and the UN
convention relating to the status of
stateless persons anyone reading the
unhcr's legal obligations observations
on the illegal migration bill can
plainly see how far the UK government
are deviating from International Norms
they say the illegal migration Bill all
but extinguishes the right to claim
asylum in the UK breaches the UK's
obligations to our stateless people
under international law would lead to
violations of the principal the
principle of non-refilmant denies
refugees and stateless people access to
their rights under international law
violates article 31-1 in article 31 2 of
the refugee convention an international
human rights law puts at risk the safety
and Welfare of children and would
increase increase the pressure on the UK
Asylum system what an atrocious mace
this government is making
further to this condemnation for the
unhcr the Council of Europe's group of
experts in action against trafficking in
human beings stressed that if adopted
this bill would run contrary to the
United Kingdom's obligations under the
anti-trafficking convention to prevent
human trafficking and to identify and
protect victims of trafficking without
discrimination
and Home Secretary appears to
misunderstand the very nature of modern
slavery and human trafficking as
honorable members opposite have outlined
also perhaps this can be accounted for
with a lack of an independent
anti-slaver slavery commissioner the
post now standing vacant for a year and
the previous order of this post
Professor Dean Sarah Thornton gave
evidence to the homeless Affairs select
committee last week and how the national
referral mechanism actually works I
would suggest the immigration Minister
cos and Views that evidence before
coming to this house with such proposals
as he has today
new Clause 26 replaces the placeholder
Clause 51 and gives the government the
power to ignore incident measures from
the European courts of Human Rights and
remove people who would otherwise not
have been removed
this close Hands powers to government
ministers to unilaterally decide whether
the UK should uphold its International
obligations Liberty have described this
as a concerning shift of power away from
Parliament and towards the executive yet
again we are seeing the stripping away
of crucial checks and balances another
Westminster power grab which has become
the Hallmark of this government what
this is really
really occurs about setting up a fight
with the European Court of Human Rights
about setting out to breach
international law it's about sleight of
hand and deflection from the
conservatives failure to get a grip on
the immigration backlog they created
thinking that if the public are somehow
distracted by judges in their jammies
they forget about the incompetence of
the mittens are sitting opposite I give
my constituents and people up and down
these islands more credit than that
their kids don't button up the back we
are here Mr Deputy speaker one of the
most egregious aspects of the illegal
immigration bill is the impact on
children and the children's
Commissioners are crystal clear on the
harm that this bill will call and the
immigration Minister should heed their
calls
I'm happy on these benches that we will
support and amendments new Clause 2 new
Clause 3 and pregnancy given the impact
on both the mother and the child in
these circumstances Amendment two and
three in new Clause 14 unsafe and legal
Roots family reunion for children I'm in
at five on unaccompanied children and
you close four are an independent child
trafficking Guardian I would like to
commend uh to the house the work of the
Scottish guardianship service run by our
liver and the Scottish Refugee Council
who do a diligent job and advocating for
the young people in their care and it's
beneath contempt that the UK government
would seek to overrule the obligations
with the Scottish Parliament has to
children and young people and
effectively prevent that system from
carrying out its work rebuilding the
lives of unaccompanied Asylum seeking
children
owed amendment 54 would prevent the UK
government extending their harmful
proposals and unaccompanied children to
the devolved Nations without their
consent we want to do better by our
Barons and it's despicable that the UK
Tory government would block or
democratically elected governments from
doing so
the new the government's new Clause is
21-25 on age assessments are utterly
ridiculous
these seats automatically treat people
as adults if they refuse to consent to
an age assessment methods great against
the home office's own advice from last
year the government calls these
scientific but the reality is that these
are highly contentious the British
Dental Association have previously
challenged the pseudoscience of such
methods saying that Dental checks field
basic tests on accuracy and ethics
the Royal College of Pediatricians and
child health have said the scientific
evidence shows that pubertal assessment
and Bone age assessment are unreliable
indicators of age and therefore cannot
be used and Gemma Jones the chair of
unison's science therapy and Technical
occupational group says that the plans
break the code of conduct of radiography
staff and their legal duties for
radiation protection by instructing them
to expose vulnerable individuals to
ionizing radiation without consent and
without any medical need for a procedure
that is not reliable to determine age
and this is important because it
determines whether children get thrown
in room with adults a clear safeguarding
risk
and the peels process is practically
impossible and the consequences could be
catastrophic and I quote from an example
given by the Scottish guardianship
service of serene Serene was 13 when he
fled Afghanistan in 2008 he arrived in
the UK two years later and the home
office treated this 15 year old as an
adult
and refused his case
he says at that time was very difficult
for me I didn't know where I could go or
what I could do I had nothing and nobody
believed my case now the guardianship
service was able to support Shireen and
help him rebuild his life and under this
bill that would not be possible
I acknowledge
I will
actually this works both ways I have a
constituent who honed offered her her
home to a 17 year old Asylum seating
seeking young man and then um he had all
of the benefits of being under 19 but
then actually revealed that the next
birthday he was going to be 24 and that
safeguarding issues around both our own
children and other children who come
from under other countries is something
that we need to actually talk about
openly and fairly
it's an interesting point but the facts
are that the medical professionals do
not support the methods the government
is suggesting to determine that they
just do not support that if he's going
to disagree with the British Dental
Association I'll take him
lady giving away and she'll know that I
moved an amendment a committee which the
government have now refashioned and are
moving now precisely because there is a
pedigree for this kind of testing across
the European countries many of the
European countries routinely use the
sort of testing to establish whether
children are African children and avoid
the eventualities that my honorable
friend uh just mentioned
the British Dental Association the Royal
College of Pediatrics and child's health
and unison's experts disagree with him
these are professionals I'm sorry the
minister is laughing in the front bench
and denigrating a trade Union given the
government's current position with
industrial disputes I don't think that's
particularly wise of them and he might
want to think about it
Mr Deputy speaker I acknowledge new
Clause the government's new Clause is
134 and 36 136 but I am afraid I simply
have real problems in trusting the
government because detaining children is
wrong and that is the fundamental Point
here the government proposed to make
regulations in the circumstances of
detailing unaccompanied children and
fraud their regulations on time limits
they do not have the courage to put this
in the face of the bill and they know
that we can't amend statutory of
instruments should the Deans bring them
in at some point in the future we do not
trust them to do the right thing here
because children are children and it
will be extremely harmful for them to be
for them to be detained
speaker I'm we bring forward Amendment
47 to try and humanize this bill because
there's a lot said about hordes of
people coming here trying to claim
Asylum but what this is is about people
fundamentally this is the individual
people many fleeing circumstances that
members in the benches opposite cannot
even imagine
so we would stick to disapply uh this
from a range of people for example
people who were under the age of 18 when
they arrived in the UK like Shireen who
I mentioned earlier and many others like
him
people from Afghanistan for example
where there's a real risk of persecution
or serious of harm if returned to that
country and you can call and when I did
the previous stage of this bill I tried
to personalize them and put a name to
each of these amendments I could call
this siber's amendment after severe
desired the Scottish Refugee Council the
chief executive of the Scottish Refugee
Council who came here as a child in the
back of a lorry he would be prevented
from so doing and criminalized and
removed Rwanda if the government had his
way and he makes an extending
contribution to Scotland
he has a has two letters which he was
going to put in the wall of his house
once said it was a letter from the home
office and you're a person liable to be
detained and removed the second letter
was one received from the royal family
when he was awarded as OB
a person who is a refugee under the
refugee con Denton or in need of
humanitarian protection and that would
cover many people who are fleeing from
Sudan just now now the minister earlier
failed to identify a proper safe and
legal route that somebody no he did not
that he says he did or what he has done
has pushed this on to unhcr who say that
this is not their job they have also
said that the tiny minority the one
percent who managed to get onto uh a
relocation scheme that they operate
it are not
suitable there's not enough in that
scheme to replace a functional Asylum
system it doesn't replace it and that is
what they've been very clean and seeing
they have been very clear that that very
small scheme which very few people get
access to does not replace a functioning
Asylum system so with my constituent uh
Elias and British citizen whose wife and
son are trapped in Sudan they are not
able to get their documents because the
British Embassy staff are out of the
country
will they be able to come in some other
way to the UK safely even though they do
have no uh the right to travel to those
that happen to be in Sudan on a refugee
travel Document perhaps with family
visiting in Sudan would they be able to
get out and be evacuated by uq forces it
is it remains unclear
[Applause]
moving to the city it would be a person
but there's a real risk of persecution
or serious harm in the grounds of sexual
orientation if they were to be removed
in accordance with this section and I
had a call Mr Deputy speaker with LGBT
rights activists in Uganda where they
are bringing in absolutely brittle laws
to persecute LGBT people up to the point
of the death penalty
people are terrified over there they're
talking about more Justice they're
talking about family being at risk for
even knowing that their loved ones are
LGBT now if they were able to escape
Uganda and get to here there is no means
by under this bill by which the
government would not protect them and
send them back so we seek to put that
protection into this bill
e a person whom their reasonable going
to suspect is a victim of torture and I
spoke at the previous stage of the Bill
of kobasia who founded survivors speak
out and I speak to people in my
constituents at my surgeries who have
been victims of torture they deserve
protection they do not deserve this film
Ukrainian citizen but there is no Ivan
or Roxanna that needs to come here in a
boat because there is a safe and legal
route they can come here perfectly
legally they can come here without
having to resort to that and we should
be making that available to more people
and I'll take your intervention
closely to what she said when I was
children's Minister every single local
Authority in Scotland bar one was
refusing to take any unaccompanied
Asylum seeking children why
please may not be quite uh as well
informed as you hope she is every single
local Authority in Scotland took people
under the serious scheme and they were
proud to do so we took a greatest
proportion than the rest of the UK we
would be willing to take more people if
the home office would only honor their
side of the bargain and the minister is
looking at me as cancer because the home
office
the home office is choosing where people
go the home office is booking hotels the
home office is not working with local
government in Scotland to do this
properly and I can tell them that he's
not working properly with local elected
members because I am aware of plans to
put at Asylum hotel in my constituency
I'm not put he said he asked me ever
opposing it I wouldn't know because he
hasn't given the details of it I've
known about this since February since
January and he hasn't bothered to get in
touch with me as a local elected member
to even discuss it it's absolutely
ridiculous
yeah
Mr Deputy speaker
moving on to a person to whom their
original grounds to suspect is a victim
of trafficking or born in slavery and I
mentioned at the previous stage that
this could be Eva's Amendment a Survivor
who is held supported by Tara and my
constituency who had come here and ended
up trapped in sex work and those people
deserve particular help and support
which would ignite them under this bill
and services such as Tara will find it
very difficult to operate once this bill
passes
each could be a person whose family in
the United Kingdom who should be
Exempted and you could call this
ibrahim's amendment uh Ibrahim being a
conception of minehood family stuck in
Iran and has been very very difficult
for them to get there people shouldn't
have to wait in situations of danger for
the home office to get around eventually
to processing their applications because
for many people that is a situation of
life and death they can't wait for the
Iranian authorities to come and find
them they can't wait for the Taliban to
come and find them they can't wait to be
persecuted or tortured or killed people
are fleeing for their lives and the home
office is very slow decision making puts
people at risk
and I could be a person who meets the
definition of an adult at risk in
paragraph seven of the morphos and
adults at risk in Immigration detention
2016 including particular people who are
suffering from a condition or have
experienced a traumatic event such as
traveling torture or sexual violence
that would be likely surrender them
particularly vulnerable to harm and I
talked previously about Priya a
trafficking Survivor detained in
yarlsrud when she was pregnant and
unable to access the services that would
have kept her safe and there are many
people like that and we will see under
this legislation Mr Deputy speaker more
women more pregnant women locked up in
the immigration detention
moving to government amendment 95. I am
saying that it's not necessary for a
person to be present in the UK to give
evidence regarding trafficking now
Professor deem Sarah Thornton who I
mentioned earlier the former independent
and leaving their commissioner gave
evidence to the home of your select
committee last week on this and she said
asking for people to give evidence after
they've been removed to the UK would be
astonishingly difficult operationally
complex and complicated very very
challenging indeed and I would question
really the very efficacy of this process
um because there is no uh recognition of
the difficulties that this will cause
cooperation with people once they've
moved away will be practically very
difficult dealing with police forces and
other parts of the world will be
practically very difficult and it's
unclear the level of cooperation that
will be required to get some kind of
exemption to this this removal and then
give evidence after what will those
compelling circumstances be and that is
also within this new recognition of the
trauma that this will cause to people
and Dr Katarina Schwartz of the rights
lab
presented evidence this morning
but the important that this could have
on prosecutions to the home of their
select committee she said the Survivor
is heavily traumatized they and being
questioned by the police they will not
be able to give good testimony she also
said the impact of decreasing support
for survivors and both their own
experiences in recovery and integration
and on their ability to testify is
enormous she spoke with the benefit of
doing it right to the person to the
prosecutions and economically to the UK
for having people come through a process
and do well from it
Mr Deputy speaker this is a dangerous
atrocious bill
it reps up rights it undermines our
International obligations around
roughshod over Devolution it puts
Children at Risk it places those
trafficked more firmly than ever back
into the hands of those exploiters who
will be more easily able to avoid
prosecution due to the measures in the
story bill it will not work we will
amend but we know amendments are not
enough to fix this unfixable Bill we
know in Scotland that better things are
possible and we reject wholeheartedly
this bill and we are appalled as in
position against the will of the
Scottish Parliament and the Scottish
government
we on these benches we see it loads we
see it clear refugees are welcome here
we reject this fascist dystopian assault
on human rights
Theresa May thank you Mr Deputy speaker
I wish to uh concentrate my remarks on
Amendment for standing in the name of my
right honorable friend the member for
chingford and Woodford green which I
have also signed and government
Amendment 95. before I do decide I just
want to say one word about evidence
because the minister again today
indicated that in his view there is
evidence that the modern slavery Act is
being abused can I he might I apologize
what sort of doing this to him again but
he might wish uh to have a look at the
evidence that I believe was given to the
home Affairs select committee this
morning by representative of the
organization for security and
cooperation in Europe who basically said
there is no evidence to support the
claim that the nrm is being abused in
fact on the contrary the evidence is
that there is a low level of abuse I
went on to say that the biggest problem
with the mrm was not abuse but the big
delay in providing an answer to victims
which of course is an issue which is
within the government's control all
things is about the length of time the
government own officials are taking to
consider those cases
can I say to my right honorable friend
that I was very grateful to him for
meeting with me last week to discuss my
concerns about this bill that I'd raised
at committee stage of the bill I
welcomed the apparent attempt by the
government to improve the bill by making
it better for victims of modern slavery
willing to this to look at that and then
I saw Amendment 95.
which far from making the bill
Provisions better for the victims of
modern slavery makes it worse
and I believe I believe that my right
honorable friend was talking to me in
good faith but I have to say it's hard
to see this amendment 90 government
Amendment 95 is an example of good faith
I would say rather it's a slap in the
face of those of us who actually care
about the victims of modern slavery and
human trafficking
of equal concern is the fact that it
suggests that those dealing with this
bill simply do not understand the nature
of these crimes or the position of
victims
the minister wants to see an end to
human trafficking wants to stop the
business model of the traffickers I want
to do that as well many of us do across
this house but the best way to do that
is by identifying catching and
Prosecuting the traffickers and the
slave drivers
government Amendment 95 by making it an
assumption an assumption that victims do
not need to be present in the UK to
assist an investigation makes it much
harder to investigate and prosecute the
traffickers and slave divers it's been
shown time and time again that the
ability of victims to give evidence is
affected by the support they receive
they need to feel safe they need to have
confidence in the authorities as
detective Constable Colin Ward of
Greater Manchester police has said if we
get the victim side right first the
prosecutions will eventually naturally
follow alongside us doing the
evidence-based collection of that crime
so support for the victim matters in
catching the slave drivers sending
victims back to their own country or to
a third country like Rwanda will simply
at best make them feel less secure and
therefore less able or willing to give
the evidence needed and at worst will
drive them back into the arms of the
traffickers and slave drivers and again
the uh representative of the office for
security and cooperation in Europe the
home Affairs select committee today made
the point that the UK has been leading
the world in identifying victims that
have been exploited in criminal activity
it that tells us these people are
vulnerable because they've been
compelled by traffickers to engage in
criminal activity disqualifying them
from our ability to rescue them or put
the UK in the position of no longer
being able to identify them and will
leave them to the mercy of the
traffickers so far from helping
government Amendment 95 actually flies
in the face of what the minister and the
government say they want to do in terms
of dealing with the traffickers and
slave drivers and baking breaking their
business model now the the Clause that
it represents which was I think it was
subsection five of clause 21 has been
used by the government previously as a
means to tell us that it was the
government was providing more support
for victims of slavery but it's reversed
that it's making it even harder for
victims to get the support they need and
as I say I think that will be a setback
for the fight against the slave drivers
and traffickers I will now turn to
Amendment four the purpose of this
make the point with her because she's
making a very good speech the reality is
that this poses the threat so straight
away the Assumption of 95 is you go not
the assumption is you have to prove
anything you go first and then somebody
has to prove you have to be here so what
are they going to do when they they look
at that they're going to say we're off
so why do we give evidence
makes a very important point and this is
why I think it's I hope it's an
unintended consequence of the
government's Amendment but I fear given
the government's brought the amendment
forward that they knew all too well what
they were doing for this amendment
because they just want people to leave
the UK
um but this making people assuming is my
right honorable friend says that if
somebody is identified they are going to
be have to leave the United Kingdom
means they are less likely to give
evidence we will not catch so many uh
and prosecute so many traffickers and
slave drivers and sadly all too often
those individuals will return to a
country where they will be straight into
the arms of the traffickers and slave
drivers again
now all Amendment four the purpose is
very simple which is to ensure that
those victims who are in exploitation in
slavery here in the UK are able to
continue to access the support they need
which will enable them to find a new
life here or indeed in their home
country because not everybody who's been
trafficked here for slavery uh wants to
stay in the UK many of them want to
return home but they're given the
support that enables that to be possible
but
article Amendment four if that was
accepted would actually ensure that it
would be more likely that the criminals
were caught
what this bill says does is says if
you're a victim of modern slavery you
came here illegally we would detain and
Deport you because your slavery is
secondary to your immigration status
now it's always been important to
separate modern slavery from immigration
status
modern slavery is not a migration issue
not least because more than half of
those are referred to the nrm here in
the UK for modern slavery are actually
UK citizens here in the United Kingdom
modern slavery is the greatest human
rights issue of our time
the approach in this bill I believe will
have several ramifications
I believe it will consign victims to
remain in slavery the government will be
ensuring that more people will stay
enslaved and in exploitation as a result
of this film because it will give the
slave drivers it will give the
traffickers another weapon to hold
people in that slavery and exploitation
because it'd be very easy to say to them
don't even think about trying to escape
from the misery of your life from the
suffering we are subjecting you to
because all the UK government will do is
send you away and probably send you to
Rwanda the modern slavery act gave hope
to victims this bill removes that hope I
genuinely believe that if enacted as it
is currently proposed this bill will
leave more people more men women and
children in slavery in the UK
another impact as I've said will be
fewer prosecutions and fewer criminals
being caught and put behind bars I
apologize to the Secretary of State for
uh sort of bouncing him with the greater
Manchester police evidence that I gave
earlier but I think it is very relevant
and he needs to look at that the
nationality and borders Act is already
meaning that people are not people who
from the figures of those who get a
decision from the positive decision from
the nrm what are in slavery are not
coming forward because of the evidence
requirement now under the nationality
and borders Act uh and so that is having
a real a real impact and that means
fewer
prosecutions of the criminals
I just want to mention the impact on
children and I would urge administer to
listen carefully to concerns of the
children's Commissioners there are other
members uh in this house including my
honorable Fender member for East
Worthington and Shoreham who have long
championed through the process of this
bill the issue of children my concern is
particularly on those children who are
in slavery here who are being cruelly
exploited
um victims need support that the
children's commissioner has cited the
example of album a 16 year old Albanian
National came to the UK in September yes
via a boat trafficked for gang and Drug
exploitation
it was clear to border Force he was
young malnourished and had significant
learning difficulties now he was
provided support including from the
children's commissioner's help at hand
team but the point that they make is
without the nrm decision he would have
not been processed through the
immigration Asylum routers quickly and
he would not have received the adequate
support to meet his needs upon receiving
the positive decision to the nrm the
social care team were able to transfer
him to a suitable placement but that
individual that 16 year old would
otherwise have found themselves being
detained potentially detained and
deported by the government so it is
important that we consider the impact on
children who are victims of slavery I
put the arguments earlier about making
it harder to prosecute the slave drivers
and that covers child victims as well
but there may well be an added element
for the traffickers to use to keep
children enslaved and by this I mean the
situation in Rwanda according to UNICEF
in Rwanda over half of all girls in six
hours 10 boys experience some form of
violence during childhood children are
usually abused by people they know
parents neighbors teachers romantic
Partners or friends only around 60 of
girls in Rwanda who are victims of
violence tell someone about it and the
rate is even lower for boys now I
recognize that quote from UNICEF relates
to people children within an environment
in a community being abused by people
they know but it is hardly conducive to
an environment of the good care of
children
Amendment 4 removes the problem by
ensuring that those identified as being
exploited into slavery here in the UK
would still be able to have access to
support provided under modern slavery
act we've led the world in providing
support for those in slavery by what
we've done here in the United Kingdom
this bill significantly damages the
operation of that act it's bad for
victims it's bad for the prosecution of
slave drivers and it's bad for the
reputation of the United Kingdom now I
was grateful that the Secretary of State
and my right honorable friend said from
the dispatch box that he was willing to
talk and listen to us and see if we can
find a way through this I say to him
quite simply that the the best way
through this is amendment four that is
what removes the problem in relation to
the victims of modern slavery so I hope
the government is going to be willing to
look very carefully at that amendment to
listen to what we have said what we're
talking about is not just what we say
but actually what those who are
identifying and dealing with the victims
of modern slavery are experiencing day
in and day out they worry
that more people will be in slavery as a
result of this bill
order
I'll now announce the result of the
ballot hole today for the election of
the chair of the new energy security and
Net Zero committee
384 votes were cast none of which was
invalid
there were two rounds of counting
there were 362 active votes in the final
round excluding those ballot papers
whose preferences have been exhaustive
the quota to be reached was therefore
182 votes
Angus Brendan McNeil was elected chair
with 188 votes
he will take up his post immediately and
I congratulate him on his election
results of the count under the
alternative vote system will be made
available as soon as possible in the
vote office and published on the
internet
now going to call then Diana Johnson
after which
I shall have to impose a five minutes
limit on speeches Dean's Island joints
and it is a great pleasure to follow the
right honorable lady for maidenhead and
can I thank her for highlighting the
evidence that we heard this morning at
the home Affairs select committee on the
issue of trafficking and modern slavery
and just again pay tribute to the work
that she did around that pioneering
piece of legislation in 2015.
I think she's actually right that the
government don't fully understand the
law in this area of modern slavery and
trafficking and I want to support what
she said about Amendment 95 and
Amendment 4.
um I noted that the minister when he
started said that it is important that
we get this bill right and it is
absolutely important we get this bill
right and I want to again express my
concerns about the lack of an impact
assessment on this bill as we enter this
final stretch for this house to have the
opportunity to debate and amend this
bill the Bill's impact assessment is now
seven weeks late and it is wholly
unacceptable that the house is being
forced to pass this very significant
legislation with no firm analysis on
whether this will actually work and what
the cost will be according to the
refugee Council the bill could be as
much as nine billion pounds over the
next three years and I just want again
to refer to the home Affairs select
committee report on Small Boat Crossings
where we were very clear about the need
for evidence-based policy making and it
is very regrettable that we have this
bill which is being forced through
really at Breakneck speed with no time
for pre-legic pre-legis scrutiny and I
know the minister is now having to bring
lots of amendments forward government
amendments uh to deal with issues that
perhaps should have been thought through
before and of course we've heard that
he's going to reconsider the issues
around modern slavery and trafficking as
well
um I want to just move on to the
Amendments that I've tabled in my name
but I just want to raise two particular
issues the homophone Select Committee in
the report I just referred to made it
very clear that International
cooperation respect and Trust were
essential to building The Joint
framework with other countries to tackle
the problem of irregular migration
so I am disturbed that the government is
hardening their stance on the echr and I
strongly oppose their latest Amendment
on interim relief
which I believe
um will breach our International
obligations and of course we've just had
two very eminent lawyers in this chamber
uh United really in what they think that
this is doing and the former Attorney
General said that this was setting out
in legislation to allow the deliberate a
disobeying of our obligations
for giving way and congratulate her on
the Amendments that she's put down and
the work that she does for the select
committee
um would she agree with my constituents
who've written to me that precisely on
the issue she's just talking about this
really risks our reputation
internationally is providing safe haven
for those who seek protection from
persecution and that really we need to
do all we can to make sure that that
reputation is maintained
absolutely agree with what my honorable
friend has just said and reputation is
important in this area and I think the
approach that's going to be taken on
this particular point will hurt our
country more than it helps us for
example it will not help us to get a
returns agreement with EU countries
which I think we all agree is necessary
if we are going to start to tackle
irregular migration now likewise whilst
welcoming the government introducing
measures in this bill on Provisions for
legal aid I think that is a positive
step forward I am concerned that they
don't acknowledge that there are
currently legal aid deserts across the
country that leave genuine Asylum
Seekers and refugees and victims of
trafficking without resource to legal
advice the sector is actually on the
point of collapse and access to oisc
regulated advice is really hard to come
by for the many people who desperately
need it so I hope that the minister May
well be able to say out how and people
will be able to access that legal advice
and assistance
can I also just refer to new Clause 8
and Amendment level 11 and welcome the
government moving on the safe and legal
routes and that again is in line with
recommendations that the home Affairs
select committee made in its report
now at committee stage I raised several
concerns with the minister about the
lack of consideration to vulnerable
children within the bill this bill
creates broad powers to to detain
unaccompanied children removing
essential safeguards and time limits
that had previously been enacted by this
house now I know the minister said in
his opening remarks that he was going to
support the Amendments tabled by The
Honorable member for East Worthing and
Showroom on the Detention of
unaccompanied children and I'm very
pleased to hear that but unfortunately
the bill has drafted at the moment will
still allow the unlimited Detention of
pregnant women ending the 72-hour time
limit currently in place and that was
put in place by the government in 2016.
it also abolishes necessary safeguards
for children who are accompanied
undergoing the protection putting on
doing the protection put in place by the
government in 2014 now the equality
Human Rights Commission the children's
commissioner and the refugee Council
have all raised cons serious concerns
about these proposed changes now I agree
completely with these the issues that
the they've all raised and that's why
I've tabled amendments two and three to
uphold the existing detention limits for
children families with children and
pregnant women they were introduced by
this house for very good reason and
should be upheld limits on detention
deliver essential safeguards for the
most vulnerable people who arrive on our
Shores to ensure that while we process
their claims we keep them safe we treat
them with care and we do no further harm
the UK has been a stallworld of this
decency but these specific detention
measures within this bill I believe are
a major step backwards for families for
children and for pregnant women
so whilst I welcome the government's
amendments one three four and one three
six and the support for the amendment
tabled by The Honorable member for East
Worthing and showroom but even with
these changes the bill does not extend
the appropriate protection to children
with families or pregnant women my
Amendments have cross-party support from
right across the house including the
chair of the joint committee on human
rights The Honorable member for
Edinburgh South and the chair of the
women and equalities committee the right
honorable member for romsey and
Southampton North and I hope the
minister will even at this late stage
consider again whether anything can be
done with these amendments now if he's
not minded to do that if not I will if
necessary seek to test the opinion of
the house on this important issue
now I also welcome the government's
change of heart when it comes to the ban
on future citizenship for children born
in the UK to parents who meet the
conditions in Clause 2 and that delivers
on at least half of amendment a tabled
in my name but I just wish to firmly
push back to the minister that it still
cannot be right for example that an
eight-year-old child brought here by
their parents would be forever barred
from citizenship when they're an adult
so I raised this point at committee
stage and it seems to me it's a
completely illiberal position to public
to punish a child for the actions of
their parents or carers so will the
minister just look at that Amendment
again as well I've tabled several other
practical amendments which all underline
the protections and considerations for
children which I believe need to be
addressed and all are supported by the
children's commissioner and some have
foundations in the home Affairs select
committee report and channel Crossings
so I hope the minister will will
consider them in that vein the
government's approach to tackling
migrants I believe in this bill remains
problematic for children there are
several measures and amendments that
have been brought to the house this
afternoon that could be adopted which
will still allow the government to
deliver on their stated aims but
arguably both more effectively and
practically
there are less there are less headline
catching ones but they will also uphold
the essential Safeguard Provisions that
this house has put in place over the
years to protect victims of trafficking
and modern slavery unaccompanied Asylum
seeking children asylum Seekers and
refugees and finally I do just want to
go back to the issue around
um
slavery and trafficking the home Affairs
select committee has started an inquiry
into this issue and we've been very
fortunate that we've had evidence from
late baroness Butler's Sloss last week
and from the former anti-slavery
commissioner Dame uh Sarah Thornton both
of whom took the view that this
particular bill will not help victims of
modern slavery and trafficking it will
do the exact opposite and I would ask
the minister again to listen to the
experts in this field and it's very
notable that um the the two right
honorable members on his side have
already spoken I think have made a very
compelling case for why the provisions
in this bill around modern slavery and
trafficking need to have a need to be
looked up once again it may be the other
place we'll take further views about
this but seriously is the minister
really wanting to make it harder for
victims to come forward and to ensure a
thinker's day Sarah Thornton said that
if a woman who'd been trafficked into
this country after March the 7th was
taken to a brothel was repeatedly raped
but then managed to escape and seek help
would be told that no there was no
assistance that could be given to her
and she would be removed potentially to
Rwanda is that really how we want to
treat people like that
hold up hold up
um honorable members will have noticed
that we are endeavoring to call
those who have amendments table in their
names first after that we shall seek to
accommodate
I'm most accessible accommodate as many
members as as possible Natalie alvik
okay Mr Deputy speaker I Rise to speak
to Amendment
my name support why am I right honorable
friend the member for South Holland in
the deepings and many other right
honorable and honorable friends
the stop the boat spill is important to
my constituency of Dover and deal
because it specifically focuses on the
problems of small boat arrivals it does
this by dramatically reducing the pull
factors that draw people to the United
Kingdom namely that once people are here
it's very hard to remove them this bill
cuts through all that plainly and simply
it says that if you've arrived here
illegally you won't be allowed to stay
our long said that the small boats
crisis will only end when migrants and
people Smugglers alike know that they
will not succeed
is the right and compassionate thing to
do to stop the boats it will save lives
being risked in the channel
and the Amendments today and the bill uh
particularly new schedule 1 and other
measures being taken will send a clear
unmistakable measure to unmistakable
message to would-be channel migrants if
you are thinking of breaking into
Britain in a small boat don't bother
save your cash and stay safe on land
so let me turn to the details of
amendment one eight four
Clause 4 to which amendment 184 release
sets out the circumstances when human
rights and other protection cases can be
excluded
put simply if a person arrives through
the small boats route they will not be
allowed to try to stop their removal
through endless legal appeals paid for
by the Bruce taxpayer Amendment 184
specifically focuses on those who would
put our Public Safety or national
security at risk this is in line with
the UN Refugee convention and the
European convention on human rights that
has always allowed countries to protect
themselves from those who would cause
the most serious risk of harm to them
and to their countrymen and women
so Amendment one eight four would apply
whether or not the country of origin can
be identified
for example if someone is undocumented
perhaps because they have eaten their
identity papers or thrown their passport
in the channel or as border officials
tell me has shockingly been the case has
taken razor blades to their fingers to
damage and destroy their own
fingerprints to avoid identification
line of my constituency in Dover and
deal this is not a matter of open open
borders further or pro-migration
ideological Dogma as some contributions
today suggest it is a matter which
directly affects my constituency and our
country's safety security and peace of
mind
a key reason why the small baits Bill
and Amendment 184 matters is that when
Dover into your residence raise matters
of concern
the party opposite the official
opposition
doesn't back them and doesn't even
believe them
when migrants are animal can broke into
a woman's house before being apprehended
in a bedroom
the leader of the labor group on Dover
district council went on TV to cast
doubt on residence accounts dismissing
them as misreportings
he said that we should be and I quote
more generous to Illegal Channel
migrants
the reality is that Labor's Amendment
new Clause 15 is a smoke screen for
allowing more legal Challenge and more
taxpayer costs more potential loopholes
to allow those who would wish our
country harm to stay here
subsection 2 of Labor's new Clause 15
would require a secretary of state to
consider putting illegal migrants
suspected of terrorism on the terrorism
protection and investigation measures
the tpims if they can't remove them
but as the minister has already said the
government is doing this anyway and it
will always act to protect the the
National Security of the country
if the bench is opposite want to ensure
our country's Safety and Security they
should back the government's stop the
stop the boat spill and they should back
Swift removals because their Amendment
pretends to be tough but in fact it
would result in fast-track appeals it
would result in slower appeals than the
fast track process that the government
has set out
in my constituency we see Labor's True
Colors it's an open borders
pro-immigration party it doesn't want to
stop the boats just like brexit so on
small boats labor cannot be trusted and
it doesn't listen I thank the minister
for engaging with us on Amendment 184 I
have had the reassurance I've been
seeking and so have my uh my honorable
and right honorable members who have
supported it so we won't today be
pressing for a vote and I look forward
to continue to engaging with him to
stopping the boots yeah still crazy
thank you Mr Deputy speaker let's be
very clear demonizing refugees won't
tackle the cost of living crisis in this
country but it might create some local
election leaflets just like this piece
of legislation we know this legislation
will not survive the other place
thankfully so the question for us today
is what are the messages we need to send
to our colleagues in the other house as
they scrutinize and hold to account this
government given this government has
systematically failed to provide the
time for the scrutiny in our place
first of all we need to tell Miss
government has no idea how to solve the
problem that we all want to fix which is
stopping the boats and stopping the
traffickers nothing in this legislation
targets the traffickers themselves
there's no increase in actual deterrence
to them no increase in sentencing
nothing about joint Enterprise for
example nothing about those people who
are illegal overstayers here that could
have been brought in to deter the
traffickers I agree with the member for
maidenhead when she said this will
simply help those who engage in
trafficking because it will allow them
to threaten those people who might come
forward secondly this tells us this
government doesn't respect the role of
international rule of law or why it
matters to have international
cooperation if we actually want to
address these concerns imagine if every
country took the approach that the
minister did when he was trying to say
that nobody should claim asylum in the
UK they should go and do it somewhere
else the whole system would collapse
it's by working with other trees
upholding the European Court of Rights
and doing our bit that we will manage
this issue better
thirdly it tells us the government has
no idea what modern slavery is at all
but frankly I'm not sure they really
care given the reaction of the
government who time and time again talk
about evidence but produce none to back
up their claims fourthly tells us they
don't really care about the children who
are already on our doorstep I'm glad to
see the member for East Worthing doing
the work that he's done but I have to
tell him I am very skeptical that we
will see meaningful change whether for
children who are accompanied or not
because every Refugee child in this
country is vulnerable the children in
the hotels in my constituency were
sexually assaulted were with relatives
those children who've gone missing have
family who are looking for them the
children's commissioner is terrified and
that's why I have tabled my Amendment
for a moment Clause to remove children
and pregnant women from Clause to this
bill but I will support the Amendments
by my colleague from Hull as well
the age verification processes that
sound like something out of a Margaret
Atwood novel that somehow the government
ministers want to support them the
removal of the independent family review
panel
finally this government clearly doesn't
understand that it's not a focus on
travel we need but the threat that
people face if we really want to tackle
it that that's why safe and legal Roots
matter because the minister can rumble
on at them and dispatch box so you can
avoid questions he can remove basic
protections and decency standards so
that we are waiting for refugees to live
in maybe the grenfold tower without
smoke alarms without saying well The
Minister's main vote he hasn't explained
why he's put forward that statutory
instrument people will still come
because it is still better than the
death that they face in the country that
they are fleeing from and we see that
with the Sudanese the minister said
earlier that he would listen to the
unhcr when it came to taking Sudanese
refugees well then he needs to tell us
how many he will take because right now
there are people facing that very same
situation there aren't any cues in a war
zone I with the greatest respect I've
listened at length to the member from
Stone and yet to find any common ground
on these issues and frankly it's about
time we stood up for the importance of
international rule of law and it's about
time that we stood up the importance of
helping people when they are facing
situations there aren't cues there
aren't Administration there's a
bureaucracy in a war zone there's fear
there's Terror there's persecution and
those people in Sudan now will be asking
those questions now the minister wants
to answer that question and give them
hope that actually they make it to the
border and they make it to one of those
refugee camps and they find one of those
unhcr people who who doesn't think that
actually they have this relationship
with the UK but he's prepared to do that
and that will take a certain number of
people that might stop them fleeing
this legislation will not and more
people will keep coming whether they
come from Afghanistan where the
government has failed to bring in a safe
and legal route where the government
still fails to listen to those of us who
have constituents who've been affected
by that they will come from Eritrea they
will come from the war zones the
persecution the people whose religion
means that they are at risk
they will come because they see what we
did with the ukrainians they see this
country and they know that there is a
better way of doing it the Lords will
take this legislation on that's probably
the point of it for the government but
let nobody be under any Illusions this
is just about May the 4th this is not
actually about resolving this problem
General open thank you Mr Betsy speaker
it's difficult to know in five minutes
hard to address the five amendments
which I have with my name at the top
including those two which have been
LeapFrog by the Home Secretary and uh
particularly given the many hours I've
been costed with the immigration
Minister and others to try and get some
of the adjustments here I'm grateful for
the time that he's uh spent to try and
get us to a better place I certainly
don't have time to respond to the very
extensive assurances which he aimed to
give me for the dispatch box earlier but
I support safe and legal uh routes I'm
glad we now have them on the face of the
bill we need a balance because I support
this bill if we're to be tough on the
abusers of our immigration system we
have to make sure that we are open and
generous to genuine assignment Seekers
to whom we owe a duty of care so the
Amendments on safe and Luger roots are
also very timely because we needed to
address the question which I pose to the
Home Secretary some months ago about how
the 16 year old orphaned from East
Africa with relations in the UK made it
to to the UK this week that apocryphal
scenario became a reality so the the
measures which the minister will be
bringing forward need to address that
question he's going to consult with
local authorities about capacity that is
essential but he also needs to consult
with Refugee organizations and others
about the type of the uh the schemes
that we're going to come forward with
how are they operate who will qualify
for them how will people access them and
let's make sure they're in place sooner
rather than later in 2024 even though
I'd like them to have been
contemporaneous here we have a deal on
safe and legal routes but we need to see
some real and workable details in the
coming months and as the bill goes
through the Lord I have no time to talk
about the amendment one eight one on
return of Jordan or 182 on best interest
and Welfare checks my real concern has
been on child detention so I was
grateful for the assurances that the
immigration Minister gave me because as
the measures stand they do not
differentiate between children and
adults on detention terms they ride
roughshod through the 2014 immigration
safeguards on child attention which
specifically under this government
specified the 24-hour limit on the face
of the bill and they don't even offer to
put the maximum detention time for
children on the face of the bill so that
is a must when it comes to any
amendments which the minister is able to
bring forward in the House of Lords on
the face of the bill I will of course
I'm very grateful to honorable friend
and very much agree with the points that
he is making in support of of children
would he also agree that we need
absolute Clarity on the responsibilities
under the children act 1989 in all
circumstances when a child is on these
Shores in particular when the home
office have some responsibility
themselves that is absolutely right and
I'm it's notable there are three former
children's ministers Behind these
measures we're trying to push today
because it's really essential that any
child in this country whether you are a
refugee here temporarily or somebody
who's been here for the long term is
covered by the welfare consideration for
the children act so I'm grateful again
there was a reference the children's act
and what the minister says earlier
because again as it stands despite the
the measures that mean there will be a
differentiation between children and
adult inter detention we don't know how
many yet it still means they 12 year old
child claiming Asylum could be in a
Detention Center facility from the home
office for 27 days that is not a good
look and it must not happen I'll give
you wait can I add my voice to the
chorus of former children's Minister on
this issue does he agree with me that
this period for which a child could be
detained when they first arrive in order
to find them suitable economodation
needs to be a matter of days not a
matter of weeks and needs to be on the
face of the bill I agree and that's what
we put on the face of the bill the uh
then immigration Minister now transport
secretary in 2014 so what has changed
between 2014 and 2023 that apparently we
have to treat children
um definitely so we need time skills on
the face of the bill as we did in 2014 I
appreciate there are problems practical
problems about age verification for
those who have a challenge we may have
to have a two-tier system but certainly
those children who are recognized
generally as children should not be
locked up in detention center in home
office facilities and that has got to be
made absolutely clear when this bill
goes to the Lords we also need to know
how and where the government plan to
accommodate those children once
identified the accommodation does not
exist at the moment and they have only a
few months to Magic it up if we want to
get this illustration through in a
matter of the month so I share the
children's Commissioners concerns she
says the bill is unclear on what the
state of the accommodation will be for
children Master waiting transfer to
local Authority care or removal from the
country what regulations will be in
place for home office provided
accommodation if the accommodation is
regulated which body will inspect them
there are a lot of questions to be asked
we are taking the assurances from the
minister on trust we will not continue
without a lack of detail where when this
Bill gets to the Lord but for the moment
we're not going to force it to a bill
because I trust the migration minister
to do the right thing before this bill
felonizes its status
thank you Mr Deputy speaker I Rise to
speak to a range of amendments and new
Clauses seeking to protect people from
the attacks on basic human dignity that
are before the house today I am
supporting Clauses in the name of the
honorable member for stratum about the
ongoing human rights breaches that
migrants endure which have been
happening for some time but today I am
focusing on how the legislation treats
those who are pregnant because not only
will the illegal migration Bill
persecute and imprison people fleeing
torture war and depression it will take
some of the most vulnerable of these
pregnant women and put their health and
the life of their unborn Children at
Risk that's why I've tabled new Clause 2
which seeks to exempt pregnant women and
girls from Provisions about removals my
new Clause 3 seeks to require an
independent review of the effect of the
provision on pregnant migrants and my
Nuclear 7 is about a review on the
effect of the measures on the health of
migrants I'm also sporting related
amendments to prevent an immigration
officer's detention powers from being
used to detain unaccompanied children
families with dependent children or
pregnant women and to prevent the
Secretary of State's detention powers
from being used to detain unaccompanied
unaccompanied children families with
dependent children or pregnant women as
tabled by an honorable friendly member
for Kingston upon Hull North
in order to cut through the dehumanizing
othering that too often plagues debates
around migration and I note uh those
comments made early today the awful
nature of the comments made earlier
today in response to the honorable
member for Glasgow Central about the
dental testing of young migrants which I
find dehumanizing and uttering of
different communities I would actually
like to draw attention uh to the house
of a real life example to illustrate the
human reality of what is being debated
today
Ahmadi najma Ahmadi and her family fled
from the Taliban and made 20 attempts to
cross into Greece from Turkey 20
attempts on two occasions najma nearly
drowned once while pregnant with her
baby daughter
she did finally arrive in the UK last
July on a boat her terrified
one-year-old baby girl clutched against
her
najma and her family were entitled to
Asylum which was granted last December
but we must not forget that there are
also those pregnant women escaping
persecution who have died seeking Refuge
for example Johanna an Eritrean women
thought to be about 20 years old who
gave birth as she drowned alongside many
others when the boat she was traveling
on trying to get to safety capsized and
there are many other women who remain
unnamed
these women are not criminals Mr Deputy
speaker but this government is proposing
today to treat them worse than criminals
and this is despite knowing that such
women are in fact victims of foreign
policy failures and the simple
indisputable fact that there were no
safe routes for them their fleeing
countries such as Afghanistan and
Afghanistan's barely had a mention today
and I mentioned Afghanistan because as
of last month they were and I raised
this at the previous stage of the bill
there were 22 people that were granted
Asylum through the Afghan resettlement
scheme if that figures change I'm more
than happy for the minister to address
it in his closing remarks but that's
such a small number unless of course the
government have changed tact and don't
think that there are women trying to
escape the Taliban in Afghanistan and
that they don't deserve safe routes for
them to escape
not only will the government refuse
Sanctuary to those that survive these
Horrors but Clause 11 will enable the
Home Secretary to condemn them to
indefinite detention
this bill will therefore see migrant
women who should have finally escaped
persecution facing pregnancy and birth
alone without adequate medical support
and with the fear of potential
separation from their baby now there is
a wealth of information and evidence
that the imprisonment of any pregnant
woman is wrong
we know that pregnant women in prison
are almost twice as likely to give birth
prematurely and that pregnant women in
prison are five times five times more
likely to experience a still death yet
pregnant refugees are to be placed in
circumstances worse than the already
inhumane situation of pregnant women in
UK prisons
in places like manston where there are
outbreaks of illness and disease reports
of assault and drug use by gods which
last year was estimated to be detaining
thousands of people arriving in Britain
via small boats some for as long as 40
days or more no one should be detained
in such places never mind those who are
pregnant and the BMA the Royal College
of midwives and paternity action have
all raised that Health Care in
Immigration detention is often very poor
in 2014 99 women were locked up in
circle run yardswood Detention Center
while pregnant and researched by medical
justice found that they often missed
antenatal appointments
on all ladies out of time
David Simmons
thank you sir Roger speaker
um there are many things one could say
about this bill and certainly my
extensive
backstory really in dealing with issues
of Asylum and migration
um means that there are many elements
that I think it's appropriate to draw
The house's attention to
but it's important to start by saying as
many colleagues have said that we all
share
the aims that this bill sets out to
achieve
we cannot allow a situation to continue
where significant numbers of people are
putting their lives at risk in some
cases tragically losing their lives in
the English Channel we need to find a
better more a best and effective way of
managing our migration process
I'd like to focus my attention the short
time available
on a couple of issues or principle and a
couple of practical issues which I hope
ministers will give attention to which
I'm sure will be the focus of debate in
the other place
I'd certainly commend the work that's
been done for the member for
eastworthing insurance and the member
right honorable member for maidenhead
and very much welcome the assurances
that have been received in response to
the work that they have done but I'd
like to start perhaps by touching
on the aspect around age assessment and
the impact of local Authority children
act duties and the need to ensure that
by the time this bill completes its
passage and gains Royal Ascent that we
have absolute Clarity of what we expect
of our local authorities and of how that
process will interact with both this
legislation and other legislations such
as the leaving Care Act which imposes
specific responsibilities on local
authorities in respect of all young
people regardless of their immigration
status
now it's very clear that in the debate
about scientific methods and those
who've read what the interim age
assessment advisory committee have said
a report that's been published by the
home office on its website will be clear
that scientific methods as proposed
envisage at best a minimum age range
that could be assigned to an individual
it envisages that the Merton compliant
local Authority age assessment process
will continue as being necessary and
required and what we need to ensure is
that we do not end up in a situation
where a local Authority or other public
bodies being judicially reviewed were
failing to carry out its duties under
for example the children Act of an even
Care Act
whilst seeking to be in compliance with
its duties in respect to the immigration
under the illegal Immigration Act
and I'm pleased that having met with the
minister on this issue is indicated that
he will return to me on a number of
those points but it is important if we
are not to undermine public confidence
in the effectiveness of this legislation
that we address that issue expeditiously
the second issue of principle which I
would like to draw a house's attention
to is the impact of the so-called rule
39 point the issue about interim
released being provided by the European
Court of human rights in Strasbourg now
the Brighton Declaration was a
recognition some Years Ago by European
Court of human rights that there was a
need to recognize the concern of a
number of the member states about those
areas where
the
actions of the Court are departed from
some of the things that were perhaps
originally envisaged in the treaty or
that are specifically enshrined in law
so there is clarity
that the Strasbourg court and its judges
recognize that there is concern about
the operation of some of these matters
it does however seem to me concerning
that what is envisaged in here is that
the only circumstances in which such an
interim measure would be relevant is
where the Home Secretary considers it to
be safe so the default position is that
we will always ignore our international
law commitments unless we choose to
follow them and that is something which
as a party that seeks to uphold in all
cases and all circumstances the rule of
law we should be concerned about
I'd draw the house to test my rest of
interest in the respect that the next
point on our links with other countries
in particular returns agreements I've
had the benefit of a lot of research
support looking at the relationships
which the United Kingdom has with other
countries and clearly if we're not to
create a situation
where significant numbers of people find
themselves at very significant taxpayer
cost in detention in the UK for long
periods of time
we need to go immensely beyond what is
envisaged in the Rwanda agreement and
established returns agreements in
particular with EU neighbors and other
countries as well
but all of those points it is my
understanding from the assurance that
I've received from ministers and the
government will be addressed over the
process of the passage of this
legislation and in order to achieve that
point which we all share I therefore
will be supporting it tonight
see Chris Brown thank you sir Roger
um I hate The Crossings I hate every
single aspect of the crossings
um it's a traffic for a start it turns
people into a commodity in particular
extremely vulnerable people
I've heard stories that often the
traffickers deliberately buy dinghies
that are more dangerous because they are
hopeful then that they will be picked up
by other people that is Despicable they
are deliberately putting other people at
risk it's also a sign of international
failure of diplomacy in other parts of
the world in Afghanistan most notably
Iran Syria no doubt we'll have people
from Sudan in the not too distant future
as well it's chaotic it's unregulated
there's no opportunity of Justice or
proper priority for those who are most
in need so I absolutely hate it and of
course I know that emotions run
extremely high emotions on behalf of
those who are being trafficked
themselves most notably they're in fear
for their lives they're terrified of
being spat out of being hated of being
in an environment which they don't know
where they don't speak the language
properly and all the rest of it but also
of course for many people in this
country who watch it they have
compassion mixed with anxiety mixed with
fear and all of that which is why I just
say that I think that language that we
use about this is so so important and I
say very gently to the minister I I
really didn't like when he started using
the language about breaking into this
country in a previous debate and using
the word cannibalized I think in
relation to this today is very very
unfortunate I just urge them to think I
know he's a decent man
um I I just urge him to think about that
language
um I don't incidentally buy the
fundamental premise of the bill either
if it really were trying to prevent some
kind of deterrent then I think this
would have been thought through much
more carefully I don't believe deterrent
is really the matter of it
push factors are far more significant in
determining who ends up on a boat then
the pull factors in the UK and insofar
as there is any evidence as to what the
pull factors are they are that um we
speak English in the UK and that and
lots of people who are more likely to
speak English than French or German or
Italian or Spanish and secondly that
they have already have other family
Connections in the UK so they think they
might be able to base themselves here
more easily and thirdly we have the rule
of law and all of those things are not
going to change I I passionately dislike
the interaction with the modern slavery
legislation in the UK the the right
honorable member for maidenhead has said
it far more effectively than I
um but I just look at Amendment 95 this
is the worst piece of gobbledygook I've
ever seen and introduced and the
secretary of state must assume for the
purposes and that it is not necessary
for the person to be present in the UK
unless she considers that there are
compelling circumstances and in
determining whether there are compelling
circumstances
um she must have regard to guidance
issued by herself I mean she's going to
be an endless discussion with herself
it's just Preposterous and I think it
completely undermines the good efforts
that have been made over many years to
try and make sure that we really can
crack down on the traffickers because
the best person to be able to reveal a
trafficking ring is a victim of that
trafficking ring without that willing
cooperation from those people we simply
give more power to the traffickers I
also dislike the interaction with the
with our International commitments the
former Attorney General I think made the
point earlier and that in essence this
bill is asking us deliberately to say
that a minister can breach our
International commitments I just say as
somebody who has probably been the
longest standing critic of President
Putin in this house and has been saying
this for a very very long time I do not
want us to be in a very small group with
Russia and Belarus as people who have
left the European Court of human rights
that in the end is a terrible would do a
terrible disfavor
um to British
um uh prosperity in the world of course
I give way to the I mean wait what the
firmware attorney general said I thought
an extraordinary contradictory uh
contribution to our Affairs was that
these judgments were not compelling we
weren't compelled to abide by them
indeed we didn't in respect of prisoner
voting and yet complained that because
we're saying in law now they will not
compare had compelled to be to follow
them there was something wrong with that
so either you believe that uh we are
obliged from these judgments or you
don't and we in fact the truth is we
shouldn't be following them no yeah but
look I think there are times when we
want to disagree with the with the
ruling of the Court we as the labor
government certainly did so over whether
prisoners should have the right to vote
and we ended up with a lengthy process I
can't even remember where we ended up on
that one
um but so so I'm not opposed to having a
disagreement with the court that can
sometimes happen but I think that what
the bill asks us to do is to say that
the government and and especially with
the Amendments that have been tabled I'm
afraid in in his name and the name of
others is deliberately asking a
government to front it up with the
European court and the European
convention on human rights I think that
that in the end will do us long time
harm when we want to have a conversation
with China about abiding by
International rule rules-based order I
think it just makes it more difficult
for us to do that when we are offending
our own treaty obligations it's a
perfectly legitimate question that labor
MPS often get asked well what would you
do if you don't believe in this bill
what would you do and well for me I
think the first thing I referred to it
earlier is I think I want to you a
comprehensive scrutin a security treaty
between the United Kingdom and the
European Union I think that that was
what we always wanted at the beginning
of the leaving of the brexit process the
right number lady was quite right to
argue for it and I don't know why that
isn't on the table again now it would
solve many of the problems that we're
seeking to address here and secondly of
course we should make it more easier to
arrest the traffickers we need to devote
more time energy money and international
cooperation to make that happen and
thirdly we need to process the backlog
faster because the more people who are
stuck in the backlog for months and
months and months the more the costs to
the British people the more there are
hotels or whatever other arrangements
that are made and that is wrong finally
I honestly don't think that anybody will
be proud of this legislation in five or
10 years time or 20 years time I think
it will all be undone I hope by a future
government and but I don't even think
that the minute the immigration Minister
will be mentioning it in his memoirs
so John has
absolutely grateful uh Mr Speaker Edmund
Burke said the Justice itself is the
greatest standing policy of civil
society and any eminent departure from
it and any circumstances lies under the
suspicion being no policy at all Mr
Speaker defending our borders and our
ability as a Sovereign Nation to remove
people who have no legal right to be
here is a matter of Justice
legally just and socially just and so by
the way is our right as a parliament and
a government to say how many many people
should come here lawfully and I just
suggest uh gently to the minister that
he needs to look next at legal
immigration and the record numbers of
people are coming here and the Visa
system which allows that
all of that matters to my constituents
I humbly propose that it matters the
constituents of members of this house
from Rice clip to Ronda from Worthing to
walthamstow just as much because every
poll that's taken every test of public
opinion says that the British people
want to stop the boats crossing the
channel because as The Honorable member
for Rhonda said not only is it in danger
of the life of those people in the boats
it also offends the principle that I
just set out that a nation is no Nation
if you can't control its borders yeah
now there are those on the opposite of
Adventures despite the rhetoric we've
heard uh who uh really are paying lip
service to immigration controls I
believe and many of the people I
represent believe I would say the vast
majority there's been too much
immigration in Britain for too long and
and immigration is a Salient for them in
a way that it just isn't for many people
opposite
and outside this place the shrillest
opponents of this legislation the
fiercest critics of the Home Secretary
include those who are deluded and those
who are devious
deluding and refusing to accept the
reality that many of the people arriving
on these boats are economic migrants
gained by dodgy interest groups and
devious lawyers to support spurious
claims exploiting the capricious
diversity of European judges who know
one in my constitutionally chose and are
not accountable to anyone in this
chamber or indeed in this country
the trouble is there are people who
don't believe in the Integrity of our
borders because in essence they don't
believe in the Integrity of our nation I
would happily the way so a lady who does
believe in the Integrity of our Board of
Other Nation I hope I do I I listen to
what uh The Honorable member was just
saying about the problem of European
judges can he refer to a case from the
European Court of Human Rights where uh
they've demonstrated a lack of respect
for our immigration laws well I mean I I
gave a case not on immigration but on
something which is as uh as if if I can
put it that way as Vivid as the issue of
immigration on prisoner voting and he
will know that successive governments
oppose the the opposed prisoner voting
including labor governments and and
conservatives and in the end the matter
was dropped when the letter was dropped
so
um that's a very good example of where
the European uh the European Court was
dismissive of the traditions and
character of how we do things here now
um Mr Speaker I commend the Prime
Minister and the Home Secretary for
strength of the bill further by a
variety of means that means we can
ensure we deliver on our promise new
calls 22 in the name of the Home
Secretary will restore the kind of
Common Sense Justice the British people
are crying out for will stop courts
granting interim remedies the delay
removal of people who should not be here
and with the public right expect the
government to remove new calls 26 will
ensure the Home Secretary has the power
to remove people who events of the
country illegally and no recourse to
stay when the British people see the
human rights lawyers making a 4am daf to
stop planes of people being deported
they know that our system is broken and
they want it fixed
and they wonder why those were power
seem powerless to challenge all that and
that exposes indeed it epitomizes the
gulf between the prejudices of the
liberal establishment and the sentiments
of the people whose power they affect
the British people elected Us in this
chamber to make laws to keep them safe
and news new includes 25 refers to
essential age assessments and that will
help to keep us safe what angles people
is the unfairness where migrants claim
to be younger they are and also game
Asylum rules just a week ago the Press
reported the story of a legal immigrant
who smuggled himself into Britain
claiming to be 17 years old he was
actually age 42 and a former Isis member
according to the story he spent up to a
week on local Authority residential
facility with children under 18 before
his lives were exposed that does not
keep people safe in a scientific age
assessments
are can be carried out and are carried
out in countries as varied as Finland
and France in Sweden and in other
European places they are well
established and they work I won't
because the time does not pit figuredly
the amendment uh uh the the whether I
moved in committee and has now been
brought forth by the government will do
just that put in place those scientific
tests to establish Beyond doubt the age
of claimants
we've seen almost 90 000 people come
here in small boats in recent years it
costs 6 million pounds a day to
accommodate them in more than 300 hotels
in order to re-establish the faith of
the British people that the government
and this house understands their
concerns won't know that it's as simple
as this we must deliver this legislation
because we must stop the vote yeah
thank you Mr Deputy speaker I I'm very
interested now as whether I am part of
the liberal establishment I'm also very
as a working class girl from Yorkshire
I've been I'm struggling with that
concept a little bit I wonder whether
the right honorable lady for the men for
men had is part of the liberal
establishment of which has been spoken
anyway moving on on this side of the
house we are very clear that the tide of
illegal migration to this country must
be stemmed we're also very clear that
the appalling rise in the numbers of
people risking at their lives in small
boats across the channel is a damning
indictment on this government's failure
to secure our borders and that
deflecting blame for their failure on
each and every person who gets in a boat
at Great risk to themselves because they
have no other option is shameful and
wrong
I Rise to support amendments two and
three in the name of the chair of the
home Affairs select committee and in uh
in the hope that ministers will
recognize the inherent Injustice in this
blanket approach and that they will
reflect on the need to address the issue
on the basis of what works and not on
what they believe will reverse their
poor poll ratings on immigration
the truth is Mr Deputy speaker that
people are sick and tired of hearing
from successive Tory Prime Ministers and
successive Tory home secretaries that
they are finally going to get tough and
sort out the mess they themselves have
made of our immigration system
to address the growing cynicism in the
country about promises made from the
dispatch box that turn out to be Hollow
ministers have to give up their
addiction to divisive and dangerous
language and headlines and get serious
about the issue of illegal migration
yeah
what the honorable lady this made is I
the eye comment of the minister earlier
today about cannibalism referring to
refugees
I I thank my little friend for
intervention I agree wholeheartedly I
worry on many levels sometimes about the
language that is used in this place and
the impact it has on the outside world
and I think that point has been made
very well by my colleague the member for
the Ronda
um and we all need to think about the
language that we use and the words that
we say and the impact it can have on
people outside this house and so what we
need is a thorough workable and
deliverable plan which is what we on
this side of the house have put forward
and which has been brilliantly
articulated by the shadow immigration
Minister this afternoon and what
distinguishes Labor's plan is not only
that it is practical and tough on the
real criminals but also that it's rooted
Injustice and In fairness I note that
ministers have described this bill as
the morally just thing to do I beg to
differ there is absolutely nothing fair
or just about detaining children nor
will it do anything to deter the
criminal gangs equally as we've heard
imprisoning pregnant women and those
with dependent children undermines the
moral basis of the policy without
achieving any benefit this would be true
whether or not the government had a good
record of protecting vulnerable people
either in detention or home office
accommodation which they clearly do not
Justice and fairness cannot be cast
aside lightly they are at the heart of
what makes us all proud to be British
they underpin our values and should be
the guiding principles behind everything
we do in this house
and unless the system is both just and
fair it will fail like every other
so-called Crackdown that has done
nothing to stop the boats it will not
only fail to work it will fail to
convince the public that the government
is serious about stemming the illegal
flow of immigration and therefore I urge
the house to support these amendments
looking forward
um thank you Mr Speaker as I said in the
previous debate I support the promise of
the bell too many people's lives are put
at risk on small boats and it is
important to break the model of the
people traffickers and we're also
spending Millions indeed billions of
pounds of our Aid money on hotel for
some tens of thousands of people in the
UK but that money
should be being spent on helping
millions of people elsewhere millions of
people in countries like Sudan I've just
met save the children from South Sudan
who are telling me already about their
expectation of children coming across
the border children who need help and
where without help these countries will
become even more unstable and more
people will be forced to flee their
homes and more people will try to get on
those small boats small boat was also
extremely unfair no country has an
unlimited capacity to support Asylum
Seekers and those arriving by legal
routes reduce up and limit our capacity
to provide safe and legal routes which
will help the most vulnerable
as I said in the previous debate the
introduction of the new safe and legal
route does need to go hand in hand with
closing down illegal Roots I'm very
grateful to the government to listen to
this and have co-signed new clause 8. on
the issue of how children should be
treated I'm extremely grateful to the
minister for meeting me and my honorable
friend the member for East Worthing and
Shoreham and listening to our concerns I
know that the my right on your offend
the immigration Minister takes the issue
of the welfare and safeguarding of
children very seriously and I understand
we must be careful not to create
perverse incentives to people
traffickers which would force them to
Target even more children and send them
on Small Boat Crossings
but
but the issue of depriving a child of
their Liberty is a very very serious
issue and we have very strict rules in
this country regarding the protection of
children I'm very proud of those rules
and many of them were introduced by this
conservative-led government departly a
child of their Liberty can have a
serious and long lasting effect on their
Mental Health and therefore that do need
to be very strict rules this is why I
signed Amendment 183 which makes it
clear that Charles Liberty Liberty can
only be restricted for a very limited
period of time
I am grateful to the minister who's
listened to the concerns of myself and
other children's ministers former
children's ministers on this subject and
I listen closely to what he said at the
dispatch box I'd like to thank him for
the assurance that he has given that we
will he will work with my honorable
friend to set out a new time scale on
this deprivation of Liberty issue this
needs to be very clear it needs to be in
the face of the bill
and it should be a handful of days not a
number of weeks that is to make sure
that children are prioritized because
children are often those most at risk we
do also need to be wary and I agree we
need to be wary of the risk of creating
an increased incentive for more adults
to claim to be children I recognize that
some of those who claim to be seeking
Asylum are actually adults but it's
roughly 50 50 of those who are age
disputed are actually children and many
of them will be very vulnerable so we
need to make sure there is proper
safeguarding in place for this group
where there is age disputed so short
time scales for genuine known children
but proper safeguarding weather is an
age dispute
there's another concern
um that's been put to me that if a child
knows that when they turn 18 they could
be removed then as they near their 18th
birthday they may become an increased
risk and tempted to have scond from care
often into the hands of deeply worrying
people such as the modern day slavery
that my uh might honorable phone number
for maintenance don't so
um speaks about it so clearly members do
need to consider these risks and make
sure that in this bill and the way it is
implemented or not making vulnerable
children even more vulnerable there's
several Roberts no rights to speak to
new Clause one tabled in my name which
will give those attained under measures
in the bill the right to work in the UK
after six months and I'm pleased that my
amendment has received cross-party
support and the backing of the Welsh
Refugee Council
Deputy speaker words Mata and I do hope
to be as balanced as I can in my
language although there is much about
this bill that I find utterly abhorrent
those seeking asylum in the UK are of
currently effectively banned from
working while awaiting a decision on
their Asylum claims permission to work
is granted only for jobs on the shortage
occupational list and only after an
asylum Seeker has waited over 12 months
for an asylum decision providing that
the delay was not the fault of this item
Seeker themselves once somebody has been
granted Refugee station status that
person then has permission to work in
the UK in any profession and at any
skill level this bill does not treat
detainees as Asylum Seekers and states
that their assignment claims cannot be
considered under the immigration rules
however the spirit of nucleus one is to
do away with this false categorization
and to recognize that these so-called
detail needs are Asylum Seekers and in
doing so effectively remove the current
work restrictions they would face if
they were indeed classified as Asylum
Seekers under the bill this is building
on previous attempts to introduce a
right to work after six months for
Asylum Seekers to propose amendments in
the other place to the Immigration Act
2016 and the nationality and borders act
the present bound means that the
majority of people people seeking asylum
in the UK end up living on five pounds
66 per day to cover almost all their
needs as they are excluded from
mainstream benefits this places them
more than 70 percent below the poverty
line
you're right that Asylum Seekers are
frozen in destitution waiting months if
not years while they await a decision
of the cases in the Asylum backlog in
the December 22 two-thirds almost a
hundred and ten thousand people had been
waiting over six months up from 44 of
cases in December 2017.
this number will only grow as this bill
effectively freezes the Asylum
processing system altogether
now
if some members here take issue with
giving Asylum Seekers the right to work
after six months of languishing in
unsuitable accommodation and in that
poverty that low low low paid poverty
then I say to them this
reject this bill reject it and instead
focus on rebuilding the Asylum
processing system so that people don't
have to wait Beyond six months to
receive an asylum decision
we know that the majority of people who
cross the channel will succeed in their
claims to be refugees and so they will
eventually be able to work unrestricted
once they obtain their Refugee status
providing that their Asylum claims have
been processed swiftly and humanely
Asylum Seekers such as Psy from Cardiff
told me how the ban was affecting them I
am losing hope he said all I want is a
bright future I am young I can work and
I am ready to start tomorrow and fund
myself doesn't he sound like a young
Tory foreign
overturning the ban has widespread
public support with a 2020 petition to
the home office reaching a hundred and
eighty thousand signatories and a 2022
poll showing that 81 of the public
supports the right to work for people
seeking asylum in the UK I will of
course give one
I Thank The Honorable lady for giving
way and I think she's making an
excellent excellent point and in fact
the government should take this on board
because one of the reasons we are told
about wanting to curb this is the cost
to the public Perth about maintaining
people if they're allowed to work then
we won't have to pay them to be in fact
in accommodation or have to pay the
benefit so it benefits the win-win
situation indeed it is we know that we
we know that our economy is suffering
from chronic labor shortages yeah and
that in part is down to brexit why can
we not think out of the box and stop
looking at people as a problem and
looking at people as part of the
solution I know this very well because
especito in in my constituency has
closed its Wards because we cannot get
nurses I represent an area with an older
demographic we cannot get carers and yet
what are we now a week away from the
local elections in England this is what
we're talking about we are not thinking
sensibly in the 21st century
meanwhile of course highly skilled
Asylum Seekers are sitting idle in
detention centers centers eager to work
Keen to contribute to our society but
banned from doing so
there are 1.2 million job vacancies in
the UK businesses are crying out for
workers 70 of businesses want to give
Asylum Seekers the right to work after
six months new Clause one allows those
people detain for six months or more to
apply for permission to work including
self-employment and voluntary work this
could do so much this could be such a
boost for our economy and we are
suffering as I said after brexit this
right to work is a fundamental human
right and it's crucial for the
well-being of Asylum Seekers and their
integration into society it is also
beneficial for the economy as businesses
want to be able to access the skills and
experience of Asylum Seekers
I call on the government
not to look at Asylum Seekers as a
political threat but to look at Asylum
Seekers as this is the thing that the
United Kingdom is proud to do well yeah
proud to do well and proud to hold our
heads up high within the global order we
are proud of that and that these people
are a potential people are a potential
they always are and people are not a
threat and we should be using working
with that potential as best we can yeah
Laura virus thank you Mr Deputy speaker
I spent considerable time in the last
debate addressing the European
convention on human rights and the house
will be relieved to hear that I'm not
going to do the same thing again but I
will just say one thing The Honorable
member for South Holland in the deepings
is correct we have no say over who sits
in the European Court of Human Rights
but no MP has any say over who sits in
the Supreme Court of this country either
and the reason why nobody is able to
give me an example of the of the
European Court interfering with a
material change to our domestic
immigration laws is because there isn't
one but just in the time that I have I
did want to congratulate the government
for reaching an agreement with the
member for East Worthing and Shoreham or
new Clause 8 which I think gives the
bill moral Clarity the aim of this bill
is to extinguish a route not a right the
bill says that if you enter the United
Kingdom by small boat or any other
illegal route you cannot claim Asylum
now or forever but we are only
maintaining compliance with our legal
obligations under the refugee convention
when we can say in parallel that there
are safe and legal routes which you
could and should have taken as an
alternative it was already clear that
this was envisaged by the bill because
it's dealt with in the provisions in
section 51 in the context of annual
quotas agreed in conjunction with local
authorities and it is plain that this is
the direction that not just the United
Kingdom but all our European neighbors
are moving in faced with the mass
migration flows of the modern day that
simply could not have been envisaged
when the refugee convention was drafted
now of the other amendments I wanted to
talk about new Clause is 22 19 23 to 25.
my first observation is how closely they
resemble laws that were tried and
ultimately failed by the last Labor
government and that's not me scoring a
political point because I think this is
difficult stuff but a lot of this is in
the nationality immigration and Asylum
act 2002 the Asylum and immigration
treatment of claimants act 2004 but it
never really worked and here's why I say
it is important today I want to talk
about identification documents mobile
phones and age verification
all of which I have experience of in the
immigration tribunals all all of these
things boil down to one critical
principle that he who asserts must prove
I refer the house to the evidence of Dan
Omani the clandestine Channel threat
commander who appeared before the home
Affairs elect committee actually
numerous times but um in September 2020
he was asked about the method of arrival
and he said talking about small boat
arrivals I can't give you an exact
figure but I can tell you almost none
have identification documents very very
close to none generally speaking
encouraged by facilitators they get rid
of any sort of document documentation
phones ID cards SIM cards anything
before they are intercepted by border
Force they literally arrive in the
clothes they are wearing and I invite
the house to contrast that with
operation pitting when every single
person who left Kabul at haste in the
summer of 2021 arrived in the United
Kingdom with a form of identification
document the lack of identification
documents is a major problem for the
home office it
it makes them entirely reliant on
interviews trying to ascertain
background facts and language tests but
the best that it can do is guess whether
a claimant is genuine in that I have to
say it leads to a lot of economic
migrants being given Asylum when they
probably would not have proved their
case if you know if they had documents
it's contributed to a huge degree of
abuse in the system and the same
principle I think applies in relation to
requiring mobile phones in an era of
mass technology where smartphones are as
commonplace in sub-Saharan Africa as
they are in London when five billion
people use social media it must be right
that an individual who does not give
access to their phone is that a negative
a negative presumption is reached about
anybody who does not hand over access to
the phone as a way of establishing their
identity and then the final point I
wanted to address is age verification I
dealt with this again and again and
again in between tribunal in the appeal
tribunal in the high court it is not
good enough to rely purely on the Merton
compliance test until until very very
recently we have had no scientific
method by which to establish the age of
somebody of course small children don't
go through that but the vast majority of
children coming are all claiming to be
around 17. we do now have the technology
that allows it I'm afraid it cannot be
left as a matter of discretion or an
option for the applicant if they say
they are under the age of 18 they must
as these new Clauses require be obliged
to go undergo proper age verification
um thank you Mr Speed Deputy speaker
before I begin I'd like to direct the
house to my entry in the registry of in
members interests for the support I
receive from the um ramp project
um I'm speaking in support of amendments
table by my honorable
um friends first uh streatham popular
and Limehouse walthamstone Kingston upon
Hull amendments that attempt to mitigate
the damage this bill will do to some of
the most vulnerable people requiring
um reports on how it will affect those
who are pregnant those who are victims
of modern slavery how it will affect the
human rights of refugees and how it will
affect their health too you Clause 2 and
3 would Safeguard pregnant women and
girls from removal I've spoken to those
working on the front line in detention
centers feeling deeply uncomfortable and
ill-equate to deal with the idea of
pregnant women in these settings so
these amendments are vital in fact they
give every woman who arrives a pregnancy
test on arrival because they recognize
where they're working is not appropriate
for pregnant women new Clause 4 would
provide support for young people under
the age of 18 in their interaction with
the Asylum system this stands in stark
contrast to the government's obsession
with trying to discredit and dehumanize
children either by putting forward bogus
scientific assessments to determine
their age or bizarrely claiming that
they are granting safety to Children is
some sort of pull factor and I say that
as a biomedical scientist lobotomies
work well well widespread across the
globe that doesn't mean that they were
scientifically valid and accurate or
even moral just because someone's doing
it elsewhere doesn't mean we have to do
it here Mr Deputy speaker when the
evidence is so poor on their accuracy Mr
Deputy speaker it is a damning
indictment of this bill that my
honorable friends have needed to move
this extensive list of new Clauses
um the protections they attempt to
introduce are out strips only by the
Litany of Rights this government are
attempting to remove from some of the
most vulnerable people in the world
that these are content
um contemporable proposals that have
been tabled um for entirely cynical
reasons they say they want to stop the
boats we all want to stop the boats Mr
Stephanie speaker but when they say stop
the boats it's not because they want to
end the crisis in the channel it's not
because they want to have safe borders
where people do not die on them it's
because they don't it's not because they
want to end the suffering of people who
are trying to come here to claim Asylum
it's not even because they want to end
the horror of people drowning as they
attempt to reach refuge in the UK it's
because they are intent on vilifying
people who have survived some of the
most harrowing and very worst things
human beings can go through and I know
that because I've spoken with many many
refugees and asylums because you've come
here on boats
that's because on these big issues Mr
substitute speaker they have no answers
so they're resorting to scapegoats it is
clear that this has been a jet an agenda
long before this bill has been presented
uh and it's clear that the government is
being pushed around by a very very small
and extreme group within the
conservative party just look at
government new Clause 22. the amendment
shamefully bars the UK courts from
interim measures to stop someone from
being deported if they bring a legal
Channel challenge the government claims
that they're considering fairness and
the rule of law and that that's a key
British principle and a British value
well this sheds that
they only there were only too Keen to
undermine these principles if it helps
them in scapegoating as the most
vulnerable they want to bypass the
European Court of Human Rights and harm
Britain standing in the world eroding
the foundations of international Refugee
systems and the refugee convention all
to appease backbenches and thrown red
nates or small portion of their base
The Honorable lady is making an
excellent point and would she agree with
me that part of all of these dog whistle
politics is what the conservative party
Deputy chairman said that the next
election is going to be fought on woke
culture trans issue and of course
stigmatizing refugees is part of that
makes a very good point
um and I think it's worth reflecting in
this week alone we've seen the
horrifying news that has reached us
about Sudan and the horrific
circumstances not the not only British
and Jewel
um Nationals are facing but everyone is
the done is facing and while Britain are
working hard to evacuate our own
citizens we're not talking about safe
routes for Sudanese refugees we're not
talking about their home for Sudan
schemes no dedicated resettable routes
no numbers
confirmed about what what countries the
unhcr should be prioritizing and trying
to help with what the minister was
outlining earlier even the government
nc8 the best this bill could offer is a
commitment to a report on safe routes
but no actual tangible commitments to
new open new ones what are the people
fleeing war and persecution in Sudan or
anywhere else supposed to do with that
by the time anything comes from this
report it'll be too late for them
they'll be on their way
for the Amendments I cited earlier
um have been tabled because no serious
attempt has been made in this build to
ensure that vulnerable people are
protected that's been outlined very well
within the discussion that we've had
around modern slavery so I won't add to
that
the purpose of this is the complete
opposite of providing safe and legal
routes for people to claim Asylum it's
at its core these proposals aren't about
helping anyone or making anyone safer
not making our borders safer there are
simply about attacking the rights of
refugees for the sake of electoral
expedience and managing unruly
government backbenches
how at the center of this is a paradox
how can you claim Asylum if you're not
on UK soil and you have to be on UK soil
to claim as Island how can you take a
safe and legal route if there is no safe
and legal route that works for you
or is available to you how can you
claim safety in the first country that
you get to if that is a country that
persecutes you because you're a LGBT or
because you have a disability or
religion
so William cash
Deputy speaker thank you um I want to
just start I'm I'm asking a big question
which is what is this bill ultimately
going to achieve and the position is
really this that when the European
convention on human rights was brought
in we're talking about in the 1950s
I absolutely would have agreed with
every word that was said in its
application to the Holocaust and to
genuine refugees but what we've
witnessed recently has been a phenomenon
which has been this small boats problem
and it doesn't just affect the United
Kingdom it affects Italy and I gather
Maloney is coming over to see the Prime
Minister tomorrow and she's certainly
going to have something to say about
that
the problem is endemic and it has to be
dealt with I now move to the question of
how you do it you have to pass an act of
parliament that's what we're doing now
the third question is what is the impact
of parliamentary sovereignty on the
questions of the interpretation by the
courts of Acts of parliament in the
human rights act when I was in the house
in 1998
in fact as it happens the conservative
party voted against the second reading
of the Human Rights Act in 1998 which
people often forget
the reality however is that as things
have progressed
we need to bear in mind what for example
Jack straw said and I'm speaking now to
the labor front bench where he talked
about the importance of the sovereignty
of Parliament
which was one of the profound strengths
of our system he said and he referred to
it as the fundamental position
established in our constitution
Derry Irvin said much the same in the
House of Lords the reality is that the
sovereignty of parliament is not just
confined to the European Union question
it's also it also applies to the human
rights questions and the labor party
were absolutely explicit about that at
the time
the position is that by the end of the
legislation when it was passed
eventually
we arrived at the point in which the
legal sovereignty continued to rest with
Parliament
and the government in the words of a
labor supporter said that they had
retrieved the first constitution of
democratic socialism by ensuring the
sovereignty of Parliament
the turning to the questions that we
have in front of us in new Clause 17 and
22 this is about restricting interim
relief and also dealing with the
question of serious harm in its
interpretation
the courts according to Lord Bingham who
by any standards is the greatest jurist
in our the last few Generations made it
clear in chapter 12 of the rule of law
absolutely explicit it is not for judges
to make law is it the judge is to apply
the law as a pla as as passed by
Parliament and I think that is something
we all understand on both sides of the
house
so that when we ask the question what is
the manner in which these Provisions are
going to be interpreted in the courts I
refer now to new crore 17 and I'm
slightly surprised that at the very end
of this debate is the first time that
this matter has been raised because it's
about the question of what is or is not
to be regarded as serious harm
by persons who have been given the Third
Country removal notice because that's
when the crunch comes home in respect of
the courts in the application to any
individual who is affected by the
provisions of this bill I am 100 in
favor of this bill I actually would have
preferred the notwithstanding Clause we
all know that but which goes back
actually a very long way in in
parliamentary drafting tradition but I
am prepared to accept that after a great
deal of discussion the distinctions
between what is or is not regarded as
serious harm have been set out here by a
series of examples which will restrict
the courts in the manner in which they
can make their decisions on these very
very important questions
I don't have time to go into the detail
but I'd simply say this
that by introducing a measure to
restrict interim relief
the bill will make clear to the courts
the intention that only in-country
claims other than factual suspensive
claims should be under the narrow
exception which is given by the bill in
other words where people face a real and
imminent risk of serious and revert
irreversible harm in the specific
country they are being removed to that
this provision will apply and the courts
will be restricted in the manner in
which they apply that interpretation to
the individual in question this will
ensure that all other legal change
challenges must be what's called
non-suspensive in other words the courts
can still hear an individual's case out
of country well sorry time's up Patrick
Grady
safety speaker I'm not sure I fully
completed my honorable member for stone
bingo card there but we've certainly got
most of the greatest hits and I'm not
sure if the member for Dover is aware
and I apologize to her if she wasn't
that there was a cross-party delegation
of MPS to the port of Dover last week
with the industry and Parliament Trust
and we learned that in 55 BC illegal
migrants from Rome possibly led by
Julius Caesar were pelted from the White
Cliffs with sticks and rocks I think
it's just as well that none of the
ministers from the home office were on
that delegation because it might have
given them ideas for further amendments
to the bill permitting the throwing of
stones at craft attempting to land or
perhaps they've been instructing border
Force to seize the Bronze Age boat from
the Dover Museum in an attempt to track
down any descendants of illegal migrants
from 3000 years ago we also learned
about the Border Force processing
facility in Dover because despite these
myths about an invasion of small boats
washing up on beaches across the south
of England in reality most small boats
are diverted to the port directly from
Channel shipping lanes where of course
they are a major risk to larger vessels
and from there people are processed and
sent directly to Marston or elsewhere
there is no Invasion there are no
thousands of people prowling the streets
there are just human beings so desperate
that they are willing to risk their
lives to get here and despite the
provisions of this bill designed to be
retroactive from the 7th of March this
year according to the home office
website there doesn't appear to be any
significant change in the patterns of
detections since the bill was introduced
so the bill was supposed to have a
deterrent effect it appears to be
failing from the start but that hasn't
it prevented the government from
doubling down on its hostile environment
with a swivel of amendments at his table
today during committee stage the
minister took issue with a number of
amendments tabled by Marvel friend from
Glasgow Central saying at this rate
there will be more s p amendments to the
bill than there are refugees whom they
accommodate in Scotland instead of
pruning the already excessive Forest of
legal challenges that we find The
Honorable member for Glasgow Central
proposes a kafka-esque array of new ones
but now it's the government that's
tabling a forest of amendments with an
amendment paper running to 73 pages and
of course if the government had tabled
just one amendment that would be more
than the number of Asylum Seekers that
actually seems to want to accommodate in
this country and if Government are
looking if people are looking for
kafka-esque amendments then they only
need to turn into the government's new
Clause 26 and consequentials picking and
choosing which parts of the echr it
wants to apply at any given time betrays
the true agenda of the Home Secretary
and her cheerleaders on the Tory back
benches to take us out of European and
eventually Global human rights
Frameworks all together and the same
applies to their amendments which will
undermine their own previous legislation
on human trafficking and modern slavery
and these will be counterproductive as
the tree Union Congress has said the
proposals would mean modern slavery
victims who are trafficked for
exploitation are first denied Refuge
then returned to their country of origin
back into the hands almost certainly
back into the criminal guides who
trafficked them in the first place and
where the government have been forced
into making concessions these are
nowhere near adequate I've heard from
many constituents in Glasgow North who
want refugees to be welcomed here to
have the right to work so they can
contribute to our economy and society
and Supply Company proposed in new
Clause one and to be able to come here
by defined safe and legal routes that
are established and workable not a vague
pledge to publish a plan about a review
about a consultation in a few months
time which is what suggested in new
clause 8. in fact what constituents in
Glasgow North want to see is the bill
defeated at third reading and scrapped
altogether and feeling that the
government should adopt the wide range
of amendments tabled by the SNP which
aim to bring at least a Vestige of
humanity into the system which is what
Amendment with 45 would do by requiring
courts to make sure the ACT is
interpreted in line with our
International treaty obligations and
make sure that it still resembles an
asylum process rather than a deportation
Charter which is also why we've tabled
Clause 46 to deliver a delete Clause 2
in its entirety I've asked in this house
before how often have home office
ministers or their farage East fan boys
on the back benches actually sat down
with us title Seekers people who've come
here on small boats and listened to
their stories there's an open invitation
to any of them front and back benches
alike to come to Glasgow North and meet
the inspiring members of the Mary Hill
integration Network who have come here
fleeing war and persecution and who
despite being met by the most hostile of
environments created by the home office
are determined to make a new home in
Scotland and make our society a better
place for everyone to live and that's
what an effective Asylum system should
be designed to produce people in genuine
needs supported and welcome to rebuild
shattered lives and strengthen our
society as a whole the government
amendments today to an already inhumane
Bill move us further away from that
ideal but it's an ideal that
constituents in Glasgow North and across
Scotland will continue to Aspire to and
which will be the foundation of our own
independent Asylum and immigration
system when Scotland too breaks free of
the UK's hostile environment
trigger
I'm very pleased to have have listened
to this very very interesting and useful
debate and I Rise to speak to new Clause
22 a new Clause 17 which clarify the
means by which uh a suspensive claim may
be made to stop a removal from this
country and in this context I want to
briefly reply to my honorable friendly
member for Newbury who's made a very
good speech in the committee stage of
this bill opposing the amendment that I
tabled at that stage which sought to
disapply the operation of the European
convention on human rights as a means to
prevent removals and her point then was
that the English law already included
protections which could be used in the
same way as the echr and of course she's
quite right the jurisprudence of the UK
does have a set of Remedies against
unfair treatment and these still apply
and indeed they are clarified in this
bill the contradiction to what the
honorable lady opposite was just saying
the remedies for a suspensive claim
against the removal are clarified in
this bill and particularly the principle
of non-reformment which is in our common
law even without European rights law we
would have that and so this policy does
not contradict that principle indeed it
strengthens it with a clear protection
people who would suffer harm by being
returned to their own country or indeed
any country and now that relief is in
there and clarified we need to block the
spurious use of other domestic remedies
which are no longer necessary I want to
thank the minister and the team for
their very constructive engagement I'm
very happy with where we've got to in
this bill and I want to quickly
explore the issue at the heart of this
debate which is not really about
migration but about the sovereignty of
parliament to make the laws including
over this essential issue and it's been
established in recent times that
particularly in the Judgment in thoburn
in 2002 that some laws in this country
have more weight than others and indeed
are not subject to implied repeal they
essentially have the status of
constitutional documents and of course
the European communities act had that
status until until brexit and the other
act which has this constitutional status
is the Human Rights Act which requires
and enables British courts to apply the
echr
now that doesn't have the adoption of
implied repeal over it either and of
course the Human Rights Act requires the
courts to follow the judgments made made
into Strasbourg now Mr Deputy speaker I
can live with uh anomalies we don't want
a hasty uh destructive ideological or
populist rejection of the status quo of
the legal Arrangements of this country
that's not the British way it's not the
conservative way we can live with an
eccentric inheritance from the post-war
era the problem is whether it's not
eccentric but when it's deeply
problematic as it was in June last year
uh when the European Court put a stop on
our removals policy and that in response
to my honorable friend is an occasion on
which the European Court exercised in
interference in our immigration policy
and I accepted that was just a rule of
the Court which in my view we could have
ignored
but the government seemed to accept the
legal advice that it was obliged to give
immediate effect to that ruling so I'm
very pleased that we have new Clause 26
which gives the Home Secretary the power
to disregard uh rule 39 and trim order
since Jasper but we still remain subject
to article 46 of the convention which
obliged us to comply with final
judgments
and for me there are two profound
problems with our membership of the echr
the first is that we have an inbuilt
ratchet with Strasbourg rulings their
treatment of the echr as a living
instrument
to be interpreted in the light whatever
cultural ideas are prevalent or
appealing to the judges and thanks to
the Human Rights Act these rulings form
part of English law and at the same time
we have a willingness among lawyers here
in the UK to employ the echr to
frustrate the will of parliament to
refer the laws that we make to some
higher authority to an abstract morality
rooted not in custom or in the habitual
allegiances that we have to each other
as citizens of the same country but
roots in their own liberal fantasies now
Mr Speaker I also believe in a higher
authority and one which respects the
dignity and value of every human being
let's call it the natural law
I believe that this higher authority is
indeed the source of all our liberties
and rights and indeed of the echr and of
every other Noble sounding document in
the West
it's the source of our morality but the
this morale the way this morality works
out in practice is not through abstract
theorizing from on high it works with
the accumulation of case law another
statutes passed in this place now not
supposedly come out for these HR now I'm
suggesting that if there is a further
challenge to British sovereignty in the
supremacy of parliament whether in
Strasbourg or the British courts Supply
in the convention then we have no
Superior obligation to remain in it the
superior obligation is to our own
sovereignty and the supremacy of this
place there this debate has exposed a
difference between those of us who
believe in nation states and in the
customary laws of Nations versus those
who believe in abstract abstractions to
be interpreted by unaccountable judges
that are in their pajamas or not I'm
very content with where we've got with
this bill and I support it
minister to respond to the debate
[Applause]
well thank you Mr Deputy speaker and I
want to thank and commend the right
honorable honorable is on all sides of
the house for what has actually been a
very measured and thoughtful debate over
the course of this afternoon
the bill before us today is
probably the most significant
immigration bill in my lifetime and for
that reason it's important that we get
it right
the debate today has centered on a
number of significant issues and I won't
reprise all of my remarks earlier having
spoken for the best part of three
quarters of an hour had taken many
interventions but I will touch on the
the five principle areas that were
discussed on both sides of the house and
attempt to provide any further
reassurance that's required the first
significant issue was around the removal
of miners
and as I said earlier the approach of
the government with respect to Children
is one where we take the interests of
the child extremely seriously these are
morally complex issues and myself and
all of the ministers involved in the
preparation of this bill have thought
very carefully about how we can protect
children both at home and abroad in the
past in in producing uh this bill and
the scheme that belies it
the ways in which we will approach the
removal of children now I hope are very
clear thanks to the work that we've done
with a number of honorable and right
honorable members including in
particular the members for Shoreham and
Worthing and the member for Chelmsford
we will only seek to remove those
children uh unaccompanied children in
exceptional circumstances and the two
principal purposes as we've now made
very clear are for family reunion and
for safe return home to the loving care
of Social Services in their home country
with respect to the Detention of
children again we've taken this issue
extremely seriously because we don't
want to detain children we will only do
this in the most exceptional
circumstances and the circumstances that
we have now clarified in the bill and in
the course of the debate again with the
helpful guidance and support of
honorable and right honorable members
are for the purposes of initial
processing when children and families
arrive in the United Kingdom irregularly
in small boats or other forms of
clandestine entry and then for the
purposes of removal from the country
again those purposes being the very
limited and defined ones I mentioned a
moment ago we understand the desire of
many people across the house that there
are carefully thought through and
limited time limits upon act detention
and the amendment that we've brought
forward and the remarks I've made today
I hope give reassurance that we will
bring forward that regime and that it
will be as short as practically possible
there is a significant uh exception to
that rule and that is of course for
those cases where there is a serious age
assessment dispute and here the
undoubted desire to limit the amount of
time that a child is ever detained by
the state has to be balanced against the
equally important safeguarding issue of
young adults indeed not all so young as
the right honorable gentleman the member
for South Holland and the deepings
mentioned earlier with regard to the
recent allegation of a 42 year old
posing as a minor we have to get the
balance right so that those young adults
are not regularly posing as minors and
creating an enormous and very concerning
safeguarding risk for our young people
I'll give way to the island
I simply rise to say this that the
engagement we've had with him and his
Department throughout this process has
been exemplary it's been a model that
how good scrutiny can improve
legislation I want to thank him in
particular the Home Secretary for the
stand they've taken
well I I'm grateful to my right
honorable friend and uh return the
compliment that it is important that we
in government listen to the expertise
that we have on all sides of the house
and I hope that members will agree that
that's the approach that we're taking to
be sensitive issues age assessment
certainly is one of those because I
don't want to see a situation where on a
regular basis young adults are coming
into the UK illegally posing as children
and then those people are ending up in
our schools in foster care families in
our unaccompanied minor hotels living
cheek by jail with genuine children that
is an evil that we have to stamp out and
the approach that we're taking in the
bill will help us to do so the the third
issue that was the subject of debate and
again uh I think of a high degree of
unity certainly on this side of the
house but perhaps more broadly
is the approach now to safe and legal
Roots we want to stop the boats we also
want to ensure that the United Kingdom
continues to be one of the most
respected countries in the world for the
way in which we provide Sanctuary to
those people who are genuinely in need
we're doing that already as evidenced by
the fact that since 2015 half a million
people have come into our country
legally on humanitarian grounds we have
safer legal routes today but I
appreciate the views of a number of
honorable and right honorable members
including most notably
my honorable friend the member for sure
and Worthing and that has led us to the
agreement that we will rapidly bring
forwards uh the consultation with local
authorities that grounds the desire of
this house to be generous with the
reality on the ground of our communities
and councils and that within six months
we will bring forward the report that's
the result of that and over the course
of next year as soon as possible uh we
will set up or expand the existing safe
and legal routes so that the UK can be
an even greater force for good in the
world
uh well I hear the The Honorable lady
laughing at that of course Scotland
could step up to the plate as well
[Applause]
okay that her and her colleagues asked
for an extension to this debate today
and then as far as where only two spoke
in the debate
[Music]
speaking in the debate that could fit
into Nicholas sturgeon's battle bus I
happily give way to The Honorable lady
in fact the other SMP members had put
their names in for this debate because
the debate was originally scheduled for
Tuesday and the government changed the
timing at the last minute oh well I I do
fight
I do find that rather unconvincing given
that so many were able to turn up
earlier and it does rather it does
rather reinforce the point that the
Scottish national party's approach to
these issues is entirely performative
they talk the talk but they don't act on
this occasion we didn't even get the
talk I won't give way to The Honorable
lady now and the the fourth serious
issue that was raised was the one
principally by my writable friends the
members for chingford and Woodford green
and uh the right honorable lady from
maidenhead with respect to our mutual
desire for the good work that they did
in office to establish our world-leading
modern slavery framework to live on to
continue to support genuine victims and
in particular those victims of modern
slavery who have been in the United
Kingdom for a sustained period of time
and have been the subject of
exploitation here rather than in the
course of their passage whether that be
in a small boat or otherwise
and whilst we it's clear that we are not
able to settle the matter today I do
hope that my right armor friends in fact
they said so in their remarks kindly uh
will work with the government in the
course of the continue passage of the
bill to ensure that we get the balance
right
uh I'll give way to the right Journal
but uh sorry he corrected me earlier The
Honorable gentleman it's very brief can
I just suggest that he doesn't move that
amendment 95. I think the house isn't in
favor of it it'll end up being removed
in the House of Lords it would satisfy
both the members who are both nodding
behind him if you just didn't move it
advice
the the amendment to which he refers
enables the government to ensure that
those individuals who are the subject of
a police investigation or participating
in a police investigation with the aim
of bringing their traffickers to Justice
uh can have that investigation conducted
in the United Kingdom or if it is safe
to do so to have their contribution to
that investigation conducted whilst in a
safe Third Country like Rwanda
well I'll give way to the right old lady
uh of course friends he has been very
generous in giving way and I must
apologize to Home Secretary because I
think I referred to the immigration
Minister as Secretary of State earlier
on in the uh in the debate what
amendment 95 does is not say that that
people who are here and participating in
investigation can actually be here in
the UK and enable to continue to take
part in that investigation and provide
the evidence what it says is the
Assumption must be that they will be
removed from the United Kingdom and it
is only if the Secretary of State reads
her own guidance on compelling
circumstances that she will enable them
to stay in the United Kingdom it has
reversed the original uh claw subsection
five of clause 21. so it's gone back on
what the government originally said they
were trying to do
the the right honorable lady uh doesn't
I think agree that Rwanda is a safe
place for those who are victims of
modern traffic of modern slavery to be
supported but it's the critical point
here is that of course we want to
support those individuals and we have no
intention of removing them whether home
to their own country or to a safe Third
Country unless that is a place where
there is sufficient safeguards to ensure
that they are protected that's the
nature of the agreement that we struck
with Albania and that's the nature of
the agreement that we struck with Rwanda
which was upheld by the high court and
of course we hope will be upheld by the
court of appealed it's it is natural
therefore that in many cases individuals
can go to those countries and
participate in any law enforcement
activity from there I won't give away to
The Honorable lady but um I thank her
for for her suggestions the last issue
that was the subject debate was
obviously those questions raised by
The Honorable members of stone for
devises and for others about how we
strengthen the bill and in particular
the question around interim measures
I'll say again as I said in answer to
the right honorable gentleman uh the
former Attorney General uh the member
for um
uh for for Devon that of course this
ministerial discretion will be exercised
judiciously and in accordance with our
treaty obligations we take uh
international law and our treaty
obligations extremely seriously now
Mr Deputy speaker uh
labor amendments today uh because as a
committee stage and as a second reading
they pose no credible policy to stop the
boats whatsoever the truth is that
tweaks to our system will not suffice in
an age of mass migration only a
significantly more robust approach can
end the Injustice of illegal migration
the totality of Labor's policy on
illegal migration is to accept more
people into our country and to do so as
quickly as possible that is weak it's
also frankly dangerous and we've yet
again seen today that Labor's art labor
is decades behind when it comes to
Illegal migration they're 20 years
behind the views of the British public
they're 20 years out of date with their
policy proposals
but perhaps this comes as no surprise
when they're being led by someone who
their own colleagues say should have
left politics 20 years ago one briefed
one briefed the papers that she knows
where the door is
[Applause]
record on immigration we could assume
that it's an Open Door
to each other
the conservative party tonight has been
united we are united in fighting the
people smuggling gangs only the
conservatives are taking the tough but
necessary action to stop the boats
because it is only this party that is
ultimately on the side of the British
public
it's my right of a friend from South
Holland of the deeping said from
Worthing to Wolf and so the British
people want to stop the boats and the
only way to wait is the boats is to
sever once
a crossing the channel illegally and
being able to live and work in the
United Kingdom and that at its heart is
what this bill does nothing else will
cut it we have tried it all before the
British people demand that we stop the
boats and only the conservative party
will do so
[Applause]
thank you very much now then uh before I
start posing the questions maybe I can
help with a little bit of process here
and that is that I am anticipating five
votes between six and seven the first
vote will clearly take 10 minutes but
every subsequent vote thereafter will be
eight minutes so my strongest advice to
everybody is to stay within the
Parliamentary estate in order that the
votes can be taken as efficiently as
possible because of the number of votes
I will put the whips in the television
rather as quickly as I possibly can so
order order
under the order of the House of the 13th
of March I must now put the questions
necessary to bring to a conclusion
proceedings on consideration of the bill
the question is that nucleus 17 be ready
second time is
we know I think the eyes have it the
eyes have it the question is that
nucleus 17 be added to the bill as many
of that up and say I I know I think the
eyes have it the eyes have it
the question is that government new
Clauses 1920 23 24 25 26 22 and 8 be
added to the bill as me that if you say
I
actually know I think the eyes have it
the eyes have it
now we come to New Clause 9 which has
been selected for a separate decision
and is it Mr connect to Moo formerly
formally thank you the question is that
new Clause 9 be added to the bill
admitted that opinion say I I the
country no
clear the lobby
the question is that new Clause 9 be
added to the bill is we need that
opinion say I of the country no tell us
for the eyes Mary Glyndon and Gerald
Jones tell us for the nose are Amanda
soloway and Robert Lagan
thank you
foreign
[Music]
close
thank you
very much
apologize
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
service
[Music]
hours
elevations
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
with it
foreign
thank you
order order
[Music]
the eyes to the right
233 the nose to the left 285.
okay
thank you
the eyes to the right
233 the nose to the left
285 so the nose have it the nose have it
oh look
we're now coming to New Clause 10 which
has been selected for a separate
decision
and I call Mr Kenneth to move
formally move formally so the question
is the new Clause 10 be added to the
bill as many of that opinions say hi
of the country now
[Applause]
Asian play
[Music]
the order the question is that new
Clause 10 be added to the bill as many
of that happening say aye country now
tell us for the eyes Gerald Jones Mary
glindon tell us who the nose Amanda
soloway and Robert Lagan
thank you
[Music]
exclamation point
excuse me
foreign
thank you
alone
very much
thank you
[Music]
two three
attorneys
today
if any questions
thank you
foreign
order
okay
the eyes to the right
231 the nose to the left 290.
thank you
the eyes to the right 231 nose to the
left 290 so the nose have it the nose
have it no look
we're now coming to New Clause 15 which
has been selected for separate decision
I call Mr Kenneth
formerly sir
the question is the nucleus 15 be added
to the bill as many other friends say
aye
[Music]
order
the question is that new Clause 15 be
added to the pillars of the country no
tell us for the eyes Gerald Jones Mary
Glyndon tell us for the nose Amanda
Solway Robert Lagan questions
[Music]
for Christmas
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
love the Lord
all right
[Music]
thank you
to order order
the eyes to the right 219 the nose to
the left 284.
thank you
the eyes to the right 219 the nose to
the left 284 so the nose have it the
nose have it and up
I call the minister
to move amendments 111 to 113 and 77
formerly
move formally the question is that
amendments 111 to 113 and 77 be made as
many numbers
we know I think the eyes have it the
eyes have it
we now come to Amendment 45 to Clause 1
which has been selected for separate
decision and I call Alison thielis to
move the amendment 45 formally formally
formally the question is that Amendment
45 being made
play the lobby
oh yeah
order the question is that Amendment 45
being made is
country no tell us for the Eyes Peter
Grant Marion fellows tell us for the
nose amount of Sol away Robert Logan
thank you
um
[Music]
myself
that's it
[Music]
foreign
thank you
questions
all right
foreign
thank you
okay
[Music]
foreign
thank you
order order
the eyes to the right 231 the nose to
the left 290.
thank you
the eyes to the right 231 the nose to
the left 290 so the nose have it the
nose have it unlock
I call the minister to move amendments
89 185 174 106 to 110 175 176 177 79 to
83 90 91 139 140 one three four one four
one one four two and one three five
formerly
informally formally the question is that
amendments 89 185 174 106 to 110
175-176-177-79-83 90 91 139 140 one
three four one four one one four two and
one three five females say aye
I know I think the eyes have it the eyes
have it we now come to Amendment two to
Clause 11 which has been selected for a
separate decision and I called Dame
Diana Johnson to move amendment to
formally
normally the question is amendment two
be made as many of that opening say aye
um clear the lobby
[Applause]
order
the question is that Amendment two be
made as many of that opinion say aye or
the Coventry no tell us for the eyes
Gerald Jones and Mary Glyndon tell us
for the nose Amanda Sullivan Robert
Lagoon
stranger
questions
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
as well order
order
the eyes to the right 231
the nose to the left 286.
thank you the eyes to the right two
three one the nose to the left two eight
six so the nose have it the nose have it
and look
I call the minister to move amendments
one four three two one four five one
three six one four six one four seven
one three seven one four eight one four
nine eighty six one five zero eighty
seven one five one two one five seven
eighty five eighty eight eighty four one
five eight to one sixty one two four two
one three one ninety five to ninety
seven one one four two one one nine one
six one one six two one oh four one oh
five one two two ninety two one six
three two one six nine one two three one
seven zero one seven one thirty three to
thirty five one seven two one seven
three thirty six to forty three eighteen
to thirty two one eight six eleven one
seven eight ninety eight to one hundred
one two zero one eight seven one three
three one seven nine one eighty ninety
three ninety four 103 138 101 102 one
two one one eight eight and one eight
nine thank you
move forward
[Music]
the question is
and here we go again that amendments one
four three two one four five one three
six one four six one four seven one
three seven one four eight one four nine
eighty six one five zero eighty seven
one five one two one five seven eighty
five eighty eight eighty four one five
eight two one six zero one two four two
one three one ninety five to ninety
seven one one four two one one nine one
six one one six two one zero four one
zero five one two two ninety two one six
three two one six nine one two three one
seven zero one seven one thirty three to
thirty five one seven two one seven
three thirty six to forty three eighteen
to thirty two one eight six eleven one
seven eight ninety eight to one hundred
one twenty one eight seven one three
three one seven nine one eight zero
ninety three ninety four 103 138 101 102
one two one one eight eight and one
eight nine
say hi
no I think the eyes have it the eyes
I'm glad I got my eyes done
the question is that new schedule one be
added to the bill as many of that
opinion say aye if we know I think the
eyes have it the eye Savage
finally we come to government Amendment
78 and I call the minister to move
Amendment 78 formally
the question is that Amendment 78 be
made as many of that I've been saying
aye I do know I think the eyes have it
the eyes have it consideration completed
third reading now
under the order of the House of the 13th
of March I must now put the question
necessary to bring proceedings on third
reading to a conclusion the question is
that the bill will be now read the third
time as many letters
of the country now
[Applause]
[Music]
the question is that the bill be now
read the third time as many of them is
AI over the country no tell us for the
eyes of man a soloi Robert logging tell
us for the nose Gerald Jones Mary
Glennon
thank you
okay
greatly Investments
thank you
this is
okay okay
thank you
[Music]
foreign
services
[Music]
things
yes
all right
now
so much
okay
um
thank you
[Music]
very much
thank you
could resume their seats please
order order
the eyes to the right 289 the nose to
the left 230.
thank you the eyes to the right 289 the
nose to the left two three zeros so the
eyes have it the eyes have it unlocked
point of order Alison Fearless
thank you very much Mr Deputy speaker
um we have just passed a bill for which
the Home Secretary is unable uh to make
a declaration uh under the section 19 of
the human rights act that it will be
compatible uh others have suggested that
it will break the refugee convention uh
the European conventional action against
trafficking the U.N convention and the
rights of the child and the U.N
convention on the rights of stateless
persons and I secure guidance Mr Deputy
speaker I'm sure that none of our
constituents send us this to this place
to break the law and it seems to me that
we have perhaps done so in voting for
the illegal illegal limit immigration
Bill uh given that we have a duty in
this place a very special duty to be
garden tours of human rights in this
Parliament collectively and individually
can you advise uh what we might do
I'd like to thank the honorable lady for
her point of order forward notice of it
I can only respond to the bits for which
the chair is responsible and I am
content that the house has proceeded
perfectly properly
but her comments are on the record
oh point of order Peter Grant thank you
Mr Deputy speaker speaker
has Mr Speaker had any contacts from the
leader of the house to indicate further
in future the intent to allow sufficient
time for major pieces of legislation to
be properly considered before being
close to
yeah so I'd like to thank the honorable
member for his point of order and I can
only speak for myself has not spoken to
Mr Speaker but no one has been in touch
with me
we'll now go on to motion number three
on the extension of pilot Arrangements
minister to move
the question is As on the order papers
which we know I think the eyes have with
the eyes have it we now come to motion
number four relating to the coronation
of his majesty minister to move
the question is is on the order papers
man let me say aye
um no I think the eyes have it the eyes
have it
Patricia and realize him yeah thank you
Mr Deputy speaker
the petition of residents of sirisham
and surrounding Villages Crowfield
Pimlico biddleston hound and wappingham
Whitfield Silverton and whittlebury
declares that the petitioners object to
the construction of a truck stop with a
fueling station on land next to the a43
slip Road for cyrusion on the rural
b4525
further declares that its construction
would be detrimental to the community
that it would cause difficult traffic
issues due to its close proximity to the
a43 slip Road alongside permanent
ecological and environmental harm
including noise air and light pollution
further notes that while residents
understand the pressures endured by hgv
drivers they suggest that there are far
more appropriate locations in the
vicinity
the petition is therefore urged the
House of Commons to work with local
residents to ensure this planning
application permission be refused
petition cyrusham truck stop
thank you very much
very much I beg to move at this house to
now adjourn the question is that this
house do now adjourn Mr Richard Drax
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you Mr Deputy speaker it's a
pleasure to speak in the house tonight
and I delighted in particular to see the
minister in his place with whom I've had
a few words
and I can actually apologize to him
because he's had a hard day already but
I'm afraid it's going to get even harder
yeah
in the next few minutes
stop the boats Mr Deputy speaker stop
the boats
following today's debate the timing of
my adjournment debate could not be more
apt and ironic
apt because I wholly support the illegal
migration Bill and its intent
aaronic
because before there's any chance of
illegal migrants being sent to Rwanda or
anywhere else
they're being dumped on a barge in my
constituency
to be fair and I try my utmost to be
fair
the situation is completely out of
control
and tens of thousands of illegal
migrants have to go somewhere
however
where they go needs careful thought
consultation preparation and then
execution
I regret to say that in our case none of
these things have been taken into
account not one what has happened is
this
Portland Port is approached by the home
office and sees a commercial opportunity
all negotiations are done in private
none of the statutory authorities are
consulted
on the 21st of March this year the Home
Secretary Rings me to say that a barge
of 500 migrants will be placed in the
port
the chief executive of Dorset Council
has a similar call from home office
officials
please note Mr Deputy speaker we were
told the barge was coming not
what's your opinion
how will you cope
what support do you need
who will provide the health care
what extra funding will be available for
the police
what responsibilities will Dorset
Council have for the migrants
what appreciation has been done to
consider the effect such an influx of
young men might have on a sensitive
seaside resort
I could go on and on and on
instead
this contentious plan was imposed on us
with the home office now desperately
claiming they've consulted widely
true
realizing they've gone about this in the
wrong way
they are now calling Dorset Council
their health authorities and the police
but after
the decision was made
none of these organizations support the
plan
and they've made that very clear
repeatedly to whom of his officials as I
have to the minister and to the Home
Secretary
the first multi-agency meeting Dorset
Council stated its clear position that
it was opposed to The Proposal
as did Health Representatives
who raised concerns with home office
officials about the risk of an outbreak
of infection on the barge
the likely and possibility of severe
mental health issues including PTSD that
some of these young men might have
they just do not have the resources to
cope
and any effort Now by ministers
to suggest these organizations are
supportive and helpful is not correct
Dorset Council and statutory
organizations are polite and
professional
constantly challenging the home office
for more information
which is frequently not forthcoming
let me ask the minister a question
who are these migrants
where are they from
can he guarantee that they have not
committed any crime
robbery rape assault whatever
I'll be most grateful when he sums up
that he can guarantee
that none of the 506 young men coming to
us
have committed a crime
I've now received the first answer to
many written questions I'm submitting to
the Home Secretary
I asked how long individual migrants
would stay on the boat
did they have to on the barge overnight
would there be a curfew
and what happened if they did not return
this is the reply I received and I quote
the site is self-contained although
there's although there's living at the
site would be free to come and go
if an asylum Seeker were not back on
site by 11 pm
the team would make a call to check on
their welfare
this would not be under curfew
conditions it would be based on the
following up and the safety and Welfare
of the individual
I'm not sure a migrant who wants to
disappear is going to answer the phone
does the minister
were they accommodated in a hotel as
many are now
I can see that an 11 pm deadline might
just work
but this barge is located in a heavily
restricted port
the only way out and back
in is far one checkpoint on a bus
so how many migrants will be allowed out
of the port at any one time there being
only one bus
where will they be dropped in Dorset
or anywhere else
who will monitor them
how much money will they have
in the summer the beaches will be packed
with families and young people
have the cultural differences been taken
into account
what happens to the hundreds of other
migrants still stuck on the barge
how long before there's trouble on the
barge
and on the barge itself can the minister
confirm tonight that it is actually
designed to accommodate
222 people
if so as we believe is the case how will
it house
506 people
that must mean doubling up in the rooms
but that still leaves 62 people without
one
surely this overcrowding early increases
the risk of a disturbance
and is it realistic to expect 500 young
men to make their return to their quasi
prison
and that's what it will be at 11 PM
worryingly both the police and crime
commissioner and my honorable friend the
member for West Dorset who's here
tonight and me we're told by home office
officials that it was in the migrant
interest to behave
as it would help their Asylum
applications
so
come to the UK illegally be a good boy
and you can stay
I hope I'm not being cynical but that's
certainly how it came across
that's going to really deter those
wishing to come here
we also heard from The Minister's
officials they were considering Private
health care for these migrants
when my constituan struggled to actually
see a doctor
and hunt for a dentist
I'm not sure they will understand why
those who have come here illegally
should have preference
although the port is no longer a naval
base it is still home to rfas and
accommodates visits from hm ships and
nuclear submarines
so I asked the minister to what extent
has the mod been consulted on the impact
of this barge
including on emergency planning
Arrangements under radiological
protection legislation
evacuation measures and site security
and on a similar vein where is the home
office risk assessment that I assume the
minister and his team have completed if
so where is it
now the police who do not support the
barge either have calculated that
enhanced community policing will cost
about seven hundred thousand pounds a
year
who will meet this cost
Dorset police already struggles
financially it being the second worst
funded force in the country
as our PCC David sidwick sent a letter
to the policing Minister and I quote
it is disappointing
that there was an absence of community
or stakeholder consultation prior to the
site proposal being launched
and I note the impact upon public trust
and confidence resulting from that
omission
he went on to say and I quit again
this means that without prior knowledge
of the intent there has been no planning
at all
in regard of policing resources
as the minister well-knowns Weymouth is
a sensitive family-based seaside resort
hoteliers bnbs and other small coastal
businesses rely almost entirely on the
summer for their revenue
as far as I know no thought
or certainly no evidence of it has been
given to the impact this large influx of
migrants might have on them
now the minister who sits here in the
house tonight told me on Monday evening
that the home office had consulted
widely
his interpretation of consultation is
very different
from the councils now I've asked the
council for a schedule of meetings in
order to check the facts
as I've said
the council and I were first told about
the barge and that it was coming on the
21st of March
on the 27th chief executive of Dorset
Council
she executive of Portland port and home
office officials had their first initial
conversation about the proposal
this was 10 days after the ports board
gave the project the green light
at the first multi-agency meeting on the
29th of March
Dorset Council stated very clearly it
opposed the plan as I've already said
since then
there's been about 10 virtual meetings
of one kind or another
in response to all these meetings
Dorset Council said to me and I quote
as with all these meetings our
attendance is in the main to seek to
gain answers to questions that to date
have either not been answered
or have not been answered with enough
details to be meaningful
our attendance should not be
characterized as taking a supported
position
but one of inquiry to gain facts
what is clear Mr Deputy speaker is it
the home office had made his decision
before
Consulting with anyone
other than the put
now
bombarded by questions it cannot answer
and opposed by all the statutory bodies
the home office is trying to smooth and
Troubled Waters
regressively diplomacy is not the home
office's strong point and a lot of
Goodwill has been squandered
it's been handled in the most
discourteous way
and I'm afraid the minister has not
exactly covered himself in glory either
as I understand it a contract has been
signed and we'd like to know when
officials told us that withdrawing from
it now will be a breach of contract
so the home office has dug itself a help
and worse given Dorset Council no other
option but to consider taking legal
action
we know the contract is for 18 months
however
the home office website States this will
be kept under review
which is pretty open-minded in my view
and bearing in mind the scale of the
problem nationally I fear this barge
could be in place for years to come
the website also explained why Portland
Port was chosen and again I quote
this site will create new jobs and will
bring investment into the area
what jobs minister
what new investment
the likelihood is going to bring trouble
personally I have received no
information
whatsoever from the home office
other than you're getting about you're
getting a barge
if the minister just listens for one
second rather than interrupting again
back on the 21st of March the minister
did offer a meeting but I was in no
position
to accept the invitation without
consulting all those at the home office
has singly failed
to consult
this is an Unholy mess
not totally of the ministers doing
but the way this proposal has been
forced on us
certainly is
I can only hope that our plans to deter
illegal migrants can be enacted soon
most importantly this will save lives
and counter the trafficking gangs who
ply their vile trade
in the meantime I advise the government
to start building secure reception
centers and fast
as this problem is not going to go away
and placing more barges in very
sensitive ports like mine is certainly
not the answer
minister
well thank you Mr Speaker and I'm
grateful to The Honorable gentleman for
securing this debate I'll come on to the
specific points he raised in relation to
his constituency in a moment there is of
course an important local Dimension to
this matter and the home office is
acutely aware of this and I will set
that out but I do think it's important
at the outset to briefly set out the
national context the situation in the
channel has placed the UK's Asylum
system under unsustainable pressure the
rise of illegal and dangerous and wholly
unnecessary Small Boat Crossings has
left us in the invidious position of
having to accommodate over 48 000
individuals in hotels at eye watering
expense to the taxpayer it's simply
wrong that British taxpayers are footing
the bill of almost 2.3 billion pounds a
year to accommodate legal migrants and
these hotels are valuable assets which
are being taken away from communities
and placing pressures on local public
services the public are quite rightly
demanding that we grip this problem and
that we end the use of the hotels
the enduring solution is to stop the
boats and that is what we are focused on
we've introduced the illegal migration
bill which goes further than any
previous immigration legislation to fix
this problem and we substantially
increased illegal working raids and
returns we've elevated our cooperation
with France to unprecedented levels to
drive up interception rates and arrests
but as I've said before we must suffuse
the entire system with deterrence and
this includes our national approach to
how we accommodate illegal migrants
in the short term that means switching
to cheaper and more appropriate forms of
accommodation such as disused military
sites and vessels
such measures are in keeping with action
being taken across Europe with France
Germany Italy Ireland and the
Netherlands all taking similar steps the
UK can't risk being left behind and
becoming a magnet for millions of people
who are displaced and seeking better
prospects these alternative sources of
accommodation
including the one we will locate in The
Honorable gentleman's constituency are
therefore undoubtedly in the National
interest the home office is determined
to work closely with the honorable
member and key local stakeholders to
ensure that the site in his constituency
at Portland Port is delivered in a way
that minimizes the impact on the local
community we understand entirely the
concern that his constituents will feel
and that he is articulating this evening
and want to ensure that wherever
possible we allay those fears in the
weeks and the months ahead and certainly
to do as much as possible in advance of
the arrival of the barge at Portland
Port later this year
when looking at proposals for new sites
the home office does take into account
the impact on a local community and
that's why we're working now with local
Partners through the multi-agency Forum
that The Honorable gentleman referenced
and holding regular meetings with
representative groups within the
community I'm happy to give one I'm
grateful for this giveaway not an easy
one for this for him I know I appreciate
as he just rightly said they are now
talking to all the bodies they should
have been speaking to that's not the
point
the point I'm making all this should
have happened before he imposed this on
us because least then we could have had
an honors and Frank conversation as to
whether this uh migrant barge was
possible to cater for look after and
deal with all the issues that I've
raised in my speech that has not
happened
and stuff well I hope that in the time I
have available and I appreciate that
that isn't a great deal I can answer as
many of uh the questions that he's
raised as possible I would say that
um as soon as it became apparent that
Portland Port could provide the support
required and before a contract was
signed or a decision made by the Home
Secretary home office officials did
reach out to Dorset Council and they had
an initial meeting with the chief
executive on the 21st of March the
multi-agency Forum that we've both
referenced met on the 29th of March and
has met at least four times since then
these forums are a way to bring together
the public and Community agencies
including the NHS the police emergency
services alongside elected officials
like town councilors and residence
groups we at the home office certainly
will do everything we can to ensure that
process is a success useful and as
constructive as possible accepting that
many of those stakeholders and indeed
residents will come to those meetings
from a position of either strong
opposition or preference that we were
not proceeding in the first place
the reason they object minister is
simply because we don't have the
resources to cope with this
you are putting a potential landmine
into a highly restricted port with a
young men
trapped in a barge for many hours a day
with a few being left off God knows
where
where are they going to go Minister what
are they going to do
what else they don't come back a
telephone call I hardly think that's
going to work it's just totally
impractical and the health services
cannot provide the resources for example
if the boat suddenly gets infected or
you know these big boats do suddenly an
affection rages through
they simply wouldn't be able to cope
these are the sort of questions that
should have been asked before the
decision was made to put this boat or
barge in the port
let's go uh well perhaps I can answer
some of those questions because we do
have answers and did think carefully
about each of those questions prior to
making the decision to proceed with the
policy and uh to apply it to his
constituency with respect to Health Care
uh we have worked with the UK Health
Security Agency and taken their advice
to ensure that no infectious diseases
can spread on the barge or where they do
appropriate steps are taken he
referenced the decision to provide basic
Primary Care on or adjacent to the barge
that was not done as He suggests to
privilege the migrants residing on the
barge quite the opposite it was done to
ensure that those migrants placed as
little burden as possible on local
public services so that it was not
regularly necessary for them migrant to
register with GPS or to take the
appointments at GP surgeries at his
constituents rightly demand given that
the cohort of individuals will be
relatively young it's unlikely that they
will place significant pressure on the
local NHS but we are working with them
and the local integrated care board to
work through those challenges he asked
about the regime on the boat and that is
designed again to ensure there is as
little issues for the local community as
is possible within the confines of the
current law which is that the vessel has
to be a non-detained one that means that
we will Implement a regime which
encourages very strongly the migrants to
return to the vessel for 11 pm in the
evening and not as He suggests to roam
the streets of the area that there will
be a secure Cordon around the vessel
which again discourages people from
walking into the community
that there will be a bus that takes the
migrants to agreed places where they
might spend some free time or go to a
shop again to discourage them from
making Journeys throughout the community
and to carefully control their movements
as far as one can within the limits of
the law
he asked about the ministry of defense
and we have worked with them and thought
their advice before proceeding and to
have considered the particular
sensitivities of Portland Port he asked
about the police we do want to work
closely with them we have made clear
that will provide a special Grant to
Dorset police that will cover the
additional burden that this special
National Endeavor has upon their very
limited resources because obviously we
want to ensure that the local community
is reassured as much as is possible and
that means that there will be extra
neighborhood policing and further
support for the police which is not
coming out of the coffers of the local
constabulary with respect to Dorset
Council again we've offered significant
funding to them they will receive at
least three thousand pounds per Asylum
Seeker residing on The Vessel per year
which will enable them to provide extra
resources and Personnel to manage the
project albeit that we won't be placing
many burdens upon them as the The Vessel
we managed by the home office and its
suppliers and wherever possible we will
pay for the services that are required
for those individuals and so a
significant proportion of that funding
which as I say will run to millions of
pounds will be available to Dorset
Council for whatever it wishes and one
would hope that they will choose to
devote The Lion's Share of that to the
needs and desires of the immediate to
population who are going to be most
affected by this project
be pleased to
because I'm going to just confirm that
this Stockholm video is what it's called
it's designed for 222
that's what it says on the Internet it's
going to have 506. how is the barge
going to be refurbished to accommodate
these young men and and what how many
rooms will be in fours or sixes or twos
to accommodate this huge number
well I'm not sure of the reference to
which he's referring but we won't be
putting more migrants on the vessel than
it is safe and appropriate to do
um I do know that barges of this kind
can either uh accommodate one individual
per room or two in many cases and so
that may be the explanation uh that in
some circumstances those uh
organizations making use of this barge
such as construction companies offshore
oil and gas businesses might in choose
to put one individual per room but the
barge itself can comfortably accommodate
two or more we will obviously abide by
the relevant laws in this space to
ensure that the migrants are properly
accommodated but also to his point as
importantly that we minimize the
potential for there to be disturbances
on the boat which will impact his
constituents the local police and
community in each of the actions that
we're taking though he may not
appreciate this the choices that we're
making are Guided by how we can reduce
the impact of this barge on the local
community and if he or the stakeholders
with whom we're engaging can think of
further steps that we can take we would
obviously consider those and try to
ensure that we do them wherever possible
unless there's a very good reason not to
up please to give away
I'm very grateful to my advice Uncle
friend for giving away he will know that
my neighboring constituency of West
Dorset is in many ways although not
entirely equally affected uh as indeed
it is the constituency of my honorable
friend and neighbor for South sources
I've been grateful of the uh the brief
dialogue that we've had or I've had with
civil servants uh previously a couple of
weeks ago but on these points he's
outlining I am very keen to understand
the risk assessments that have taken
place in order to inform these points of
which he's making I've been asking for
those for a couple of weeks and I'd be
grateful if he might confirm when indeed
they would be available and presented to
both my honorable friend and neighbor
because I thought it and myself
well I know that the honorable gentleman
uh met with uh my officials in the
department and I apologize I wasn't able
to to meet with them at the same time
because I was attending a cobra meeting
with respect to the Border Force
presence in Sudan this week uh but I
think we're meeting again soon uh so
that both myself and officials can
discuss those points with him we have
considered uh the challenges and would
be pleased to answer as many questions
as we can
see that there's only a very short
period left so if I draw my remarks to a
close by saying that we all appreciate
that whilst this policy is undoubtedly
in the National interest it has a
particularly serious impact upon the
community which The Honorable gentleman
represent myself the Home Secretary the
government stand ready to work with them
to make this policy as successful as
possible to listen to the views of their
constituents and to mitigate the
negatives as far as possible
he has our assurance that we will also
of course do everything we can to stop
the boats and to stop this problem at
source the question is that this house
do now a journals man let me say aye
country no I think the eyes have it the
eyes have it
order